This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress,
the only online mattress company to provide free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina,
it's almost time.
What's that Jean Jean.
I am about to do a one of the biggest ones I've ever done.
Ever.
Yeah,
I'm doing,
let's see.
Two,
four,
six,
eight shows coming up.
I'm going to be doing two shows in Madison and Milwaukee too in Chicago and two
in Nashville.
As of this recording,
you can still get tickets to the Madison late show.
April 11th,
the late show,
April 12th has very few tickets left.
You might be able to get some,
they're a Chicago sold out April 13th and we added a show in June,
June 2nd and you can maybe get a few tickets at the late show in Nashville.
It's,
it's limited.
Might be symbols,
Thompson or.com/tour.
Uh,
let's see.
You can get tickets to the late show.
April 28th in Medford,
Massachusetts.
That's the rest outside of Boston and May 1st in Portland.
Horrigan um,
we have some tickets there the next day if sold out.
Then there's a run of shows in Seattle at the more and the only one with tickets
left is a for,
or excuse me,
May 5th go to Tom [inaudible] dot com slash tour um,
and I should also point out that we are announcing the take it down towards
second half of the year shows.
Oh uh,
if you signed up for the email on my site,
you will get the email announcing the code and the list of cities before anybody
else on April 9th.
That's the date that an email comes out.
The following day.
It'll be announced to the public,
um,
tickets.
But you can get advanced tickets if you sign up Thompson [inaudible] dot com
slash tour,
it prompts you to an email list.
You can get those tickets and that email will come to you.
April 9th.
Gene,
you're going to be in Minneapolis,
any apple tits this week,
April four through six at the acme.
Come on your club.
And then May 10th or 11th at 10 p yet the Tempe Improv,
uh,
May 31st through June 1st flappers comedy club here in Sperm Bank,
California.
And then June 20th through 22nd and Washington Dick at the Dick come and prop
also if you haven't seen it,
I have to Netflix specials under the name Christina p just the latter piece when
I'm spelling my horrible last name.
I have my hour mother inferior and my half hour.
The degenerates.
Also Ryder Dye tee shirts for sale at our store.
What is it Tom Birch method.com/tom cigarettes.
Yeah,
it's under Tommy's page.
Check out.
The shorts are very awesome.
Yup.
You said Washington.
Oh,
Washington deck come six 20 through 22.
Yeah,
I'm very excited and a little while here.
Uh,
I can,
I think I have to put it on this show.
We should mention.
Uh,
there's a couple items that will be added to the store when this episode comes
out.
So it's pretty exciting.
Excite made pretty amaze.
It's pretty exciting.
Gene,
this is going to be a really fun show.
We have a lot of good things to play for you guys and we have some amazing
guests.
So without further ado,
let's start the show.
This is just a memo or a letter to people who microwave or cook fish at work or
just in a public space without some type of consent.
Fuck,
you
don't bring anyone in loving to this.
Well,
go to your mom's house
and
Christina.
Oh yeah.
That lady had a really good message.
Action.
That's disrespect.
You know what it remind you of the disrespect of somebody microwaving fish in a
public place is the disrespect of people who board flights with food,
food and people bring curry on your mind.
First of all,
why aren't just eat that in the terminal eight that you don't want to eat that
sitting next because there's selfish or nasty or oblivious.
They're narcissist.
Yeah,
they're just horrible people.
Paul.
Yeah,
no.
You know it's board flights and you're like year piece of shit.
Why you want to know is even Nastier when you're getting your time massage and
then the waft of curry ghosts.
They live because they live in the break room like 10 of them sleep in that tiny
little shoe box.
They're just massage slaves,
slave labor now and then,
but that's the only place I can eat.
So that's why I don't get so furious.
I know,
but that's why I don't go to Thai places cause it's a bummer.
I knew.
Smelled their pending curry.
It smells delicious and I'm hungry.
You're in the front room and then you're like,
hey,
use the restroom before this.
And then you go to the break room and you're like,
Ooh,
does it hits you like a wave your vegetables today?
Huh?
And you see like 10 people eating out of their Tupperware like,
oh,
can I get some fuel for all this work we're doing?
And then there's like a cot.
That
extra tip.
Okay.
For so relaxed,
but also could you take it out back?
You take your food out bags.
Don't microwave the curry.
How has no one's like push back on that hard enough yet.
Huh?
But the slave labor.
Yeah.
Like guys.
But the food,
I know you're slaves.
I know your slaves.
Could you please take this outside?
Catch me outside.
Yeah.
That's my curry outside.
My,
my,
uh,
my wife from a 2011 just learned cash me outside.
And I tell you what though,
I was thinking about it.
It's because I've been in the haze of raising children for last four years of
toddler and baby land.
You just last week she was like,
catch me outside.
How about that?
Have you heard this?
I'm like,
yeah,
you have you seen the right picking up
a little bit of Gina and my La Gangnam style.
Oh,
I love
that guy.
He's so clever,
man.
Guys,
I don't have much,
you know what I mean?
It's just
my life isn't cool.
It's like this and then my children,
should we talk about this real quick?
Oh,
forget God.
Two things.
Two things are coming to this.
They're in the store now.
Actually if you're,
if you're watching by now,
it's there.
So one is the battle for championship status has never slowed down between us
and we've had so many people weigh in.
That was the fun thing about the water champion.
Interesting.
I'm drinking water right now,
but here's the fascinating thing about the water battle.
Okay.
I,
my doctor told me to stop drinking so much water.
Sure.
But people have everywhere in,
in person,
in emails,
direct messages,
tweets,
all then bring out who's the water champ in their lives.
Yes.
It goes back and forth.
Right.
And they've also hit us up.
They're like,
how do you not have a water bottle?
We do.
This is finally a well designed,
well insulated water bottle you can carry around and it has like the thing that
flips up and right.
What are you calling it?
The water with your mom.
You flip it up and on it on it.
I can't even think of
the word.
Water canteen blue.
Anyways,
this shit called huh?
Uh,
it's like a builtin Straw.
Right.
But it's like a built in thing at the top that you can suck sippy cups.
Zippy.
It's,
you know,
it's an adult sippy cup.
It's an adult sippy bottle.
Anyways,
it's a,
it's got its branded says water champs as your mom's house podcast.
It's in the store.
But what I'm most excited about,
I've never been this excited about a piece of merge in my life.
I did.
If you have not seen it.
I did or listen to episode two of Dr Drew's new podcasts that we produced is
called doctor drew after dark.
It has been an amazing thing that has that like every week new guests and
there's episodes with Christina,
Bobby Lee,
a Steevo.
Burt just did one.
Um,
who else we got?
Uh,
we got Hardwick coming up.
We just Hardwick it's killers.
So when I was on with him,
he brought up,
cause we had been watching uncle Terry stuff.
Well because in my episode did episode one you did with Uncle Jerry?
Uncle Terry.
And then when by the time you came on,
yeah,
he was like revisited.
He wanted to revisit and he goes,
you know,
I talked to Christina about this,
about what do you think is the,
um,
the like the biggest thing someone should put in their anus.
Um,
and he,
he said that he think hot topic.
Well I just said like it depends what we're talking about.
And he said,
well the average person.
And I was like,
cause there's some people that do double anal.
So he goes that that's not the average person.
And he said that he,
he thought that what the biggest thing somebody should put in their anus is if
you make the okay sign that's a medical professional talent,
right.
And he's like,
okay,
sign is the extent of how great you should go.
And I said,
what about tripling?
And he was like,
no,
no.
Um,
and then he said,
I said,
you know,
there's some things that can happen that if
it,
you know,
we're good.
We're good.
Okay.
So anyways,
so anyways,
um,
he ended up using the express,
I said,
you shouldn't do double anal,
Huh?
And he goes,
yeah,
you shouldn't prolapse rain.
And in that moment I said,
I think you just made your first shirt.
And he was like,
Oh God,
what am I doing with my life and my career?
But I didn't forget that.
So I immediately reached out to one of my favorite shirt designers at Maude ink
teas and Augusta,
and they,
I pitched them the whole thing.
What happened?
They came up with this shirt and then I had to reach out to drew.
And his team and be like,
can we do this shirt?
And he was like,
fine.
So we have you shouldn't prolapse your anus signed a doctor group with the okay
symbol and they can see this.
I mean,
come on.
I've never been happier about a shirt that we've ever done.
It's in the store.
Prolapse,
prolapse your anus,
you should keep it here.
Yeah,
and the best part is that it's Dr drew approved.
It's science.
It's medicine.
This is not a a joke.
No.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah,
we got it.
Was that my step mom?
Really,
really awesome.
So this is back to gene.
This is the lady.
I love this lady's message and mantra and everything so far.
Hold on.
She does meet the criteria for a good why?
Mh Video?
She doesn't have a great set.
I'll tell her.
Terrible,
terrible.
Come on.
Any other room in the house?
Even the bathroom would have been better than the depressing blinds.
But I'll tell you this.
She is.
She's with it.
She's on point.
She was coherent.
She knows what's going on and her message come on her meds rare on our air.
On your mouth.
Her message is one that you cannot deny is absolutely accurate,
okay?
You should not microwave fish in a public setting.
Now,
this is just a memo or a letter to people who microwave or cook fish at work or
just in a public space without some type of consent.
Fuck you.
I mean that from the bottom of my heart.
Fuck your Mama.
Fuck your Daddy.
Fuck the horse you rode in all.
Fuck everybody who loves you cares about you
become apart of making you the person that you are today.
You fucked him.
Fuck all of y'all.
Oh my God.
I found my new best friend.
It's all going to hang out with her public area.
I don't give a damn.
If it was the last thing that you could eat,
I don't give a fuck if it was the only thing that you could eat that month,
that shit is considered as fuck.
You know what fish smell like?
You know what it smelled like.
You knew what it smelled like before you came in.
You knew damn well that when heat is applied to fish,
it stank.
She right.
You know what I love the most about conceptually is I just love the way the
world works sometimes where you know that she was at work today and somebody
made fish at work and in that setting she just had to look down and just,
you know,
maybe did a couple passive aggressive things like
the hell's that,
you know,
maybe a couple of things like that.
Yeah.
And then talk to a couple of people you smell that and you know,
but then like when the person walked by you had to just kind of just look at
them and carried that feeling home all day,
all day,
carried it home,
set up a camera,
made this recording and like gets like vents it out
in,
in a car.
I'm actually in a healthy way.
Yeah.
Gets it out.
And then there's the possible
ability,
probably only that someone at work,
we'll see this and maybe it'll get to the person
you,
you hope that the offenders going to get the message they never do.
Well no cause they're so Olivia that they do that stuff here.
I'm going to take it one step further.
Having,
I remember working in an office,
it's not the first time this has happened.
No,
of course not.
There is the person who's the repeat offender,
the oblivious person that does the same behavior every day.
That is infuriating.
And this is like the final thing.
You got to have such blinders on.
People are terrible.
I know.
It's the same.
It's that same piece of shit.
Of Boards.
The flight.
Yeah.
Here you go.
I brought some fish stew on a flight.
They were like,
what are you doing man?
I know.
I used to have this girl when I worked in the cubicles,
I was selling a telemarketing time and she would talk very loudly on her phone
and laugh like a donkey.
Yeah.
All Day.
And I'm like,
you know that everyone else is trying to focus and would laugh like a porn girl.
You know?
Like that nervous pornstar like,
yeah.
Okay.
Everything is a laugh.
Yeah.
That girl's cool.
I love that girl.
Oh,
that's that girl.
It's funny,
we were talking about the show you before we rolled tight and Josh and love that
show.
I know.
So do I,
where I tore through them all and the guys in the booth and everybody was saying
that.
I see,
I thought the girl,
the love interest in you,
the Blondie,
I thought you guys all had it for her.
Well,
she's a,
she is
that,
that character is extremely well and specifically constructed.
So it's not that like people are like,
Eh,
dismissive of her is that she's supposed to represent something that you're ill,
the illusion of perfection,
right.
You see all these flaws and things that you would kind of lose interest in.
Right.
Because he,
but what would you
cause I thought you guys all had a,
you know,
your smackles were hard for her because she's cute.
She's kind of a Dalmatian.
She's not causing too many.
Yeah.
That's the baits and problematic appeal.
Right,
right.
She doesn't push back.
She's pretty game to f she's totally game.
Yeah.
She's explaining it to me.
So she's not the ideal woman.
Well,
ultimately,
you know,
I mean it depends like person to person what they like,
but I think in the show,
yeah,
she's just a very attractive,
um,
the fun kind of idealistic person who is ambitious.
But then you,
you see like how insecure she is,
how it's annoying.
Yeah.
How,
you know,
she's crippled with self doubt,
which is not necessarily,
I mean that's a normal thing to feel,
but she's more complicated than just you see the first time you're exposed or
you just see her as a pretty face.
Right.
Beautiful Girl.
And then what's the turn offs?
Is that she's like annoying?
How,
what,
what don't you like?
No,
it's not like it's,
you know,
it's just like anybody,
when you get to know them,
um,
there's just different levels of things going on.
So there's things about her as you watch the show where the character you might
find appealing.
And then there's things that are not,
I mean,
she's ultimately,
it doesn't really know who she is and she's not,
she's really actually not like noncommittal member when they Kinda,
I don't want to give away the show,
but she's not like cool.
Actually.
She doesn't really treat him so cool.
Yeah.
I mean,
no shit.
You know,
and then it kind of comes back around.
But I'm just saying like,
it's not just,
she's not presented in the show as like I'm a piece of ass.
That's not really the point of the character.
Yeah,
no,
I hear Ya.
Okay.
But I mean,
I mean there's crazy,
there's a couple of crazy chicks and the show that make their smuggles harder.
Peaches,
peaches,
peaches is fucking down.
So what do you like about her over the lead girl?
What's,
what's the appeal to PG?
Well,
you don't know her as well,
so it's,
it's easier to be intimate with her
and then talk about that.
No,
she's,
she's rough.
You know she's got,
she's the one that like you could get some chains and like you could,
you know,
really kind of,
I don't think you got that.
You'd have a blondie.
You can't do that with peaches.
Oh,
I think peaches is,
is down for a good time.
Okay.
I do.
I think,
I think peaches,
you could spit in her face.
You could do it.
All right,
great.
Okay.
Moving along.
We have some other topics.
We,
we took our overnight,
we did our mommy daddy hotel stay overnight.
I recommend that to anybody that has children if you can.
Yeah.
What you do is you call,
yeah,
call the grandparents.
Call Your,
you know,
your sibling or your the best babysitter,
and go,
can you watch the kids for one that's coming to the house for one night and what
we ended up doing was sleeping.
You can't map when you have little,
you never,
we never,
now you try to nap and then you just hear screaming and crying.
I loved it.
Oh my God.
I loved it until we had dinner.
Well hold on.
First of all,
I took a two hour nap,
let's talk about it.
That was pretty ridiculous.
And I slept for 11 hours.
That's how,
and then we went to dinner and it was a patio seating.
And in Los Angeles right now the weather is on the border of being acceptable to
eat outside at night.
I said there's heat lamps and I,
I asked to be sat under the heat lamp cause I'm very cold and I they turned it
up nice and high.
I turned it up to full blast.
Like,
like if it were 30 and you're like I need a heat lamp to see it sit outside.
They did that except it was about 68 felt good.
And
then I was nice and toasty and you were sitting next to me in the booth and then
I and I,
I'm high.
That's the first thing you aim.
Ha ha ha.
And I go,
you're wearing what?
You're wearing a shirt.
That's what I hear it as complete.
Oh my God.
Fucking says,
wow,
okay.
I know.
Here's where it gets even dicier who says
crying about how hot you are so that you are wearing a sweatshirt.
First of all,
y'all let the record show I was wearing a normal,
a normal hook like that in that temperature it was like appropriate.
Like that would keep you sufficiently,
can hat take off a layer if you're hot,
but you wouldn't take off your stern on layer,
you have a mental problem and you have an the heat lamp.
It literally felt like you were just sitting next to an open oven
500 and you're like,
let's just sit next to this open of it.
And it felt great.
So here's the deal man.
So you sat next to me and then you say ain't hat and then I go case,
I'll then move away so that you don't,
you're setting and then so you sat across from me.
So now you're as far away from the heat lamp as you can be.
And I thought that would solve the problem.
But then I watched you get more and more agitated.
It was like a silent buildup of rage.
Like,
I like how you're looking at me right now.
Like that's silent rage.
And I was like,
and then I,
okay.
Then I finally gave in and I had them turn it down.
I remember.
Or you got up and you turn it off.
That was the last thing.
So he turned down and then I came next to you and I cuddled you.
And I said,
why are you,
I go,
what are you,
are you mad at me for having it so high?
And you're like,
yes,
you're ruining dinner.
Yeah.
And he was really legitimately mad at me.
Like you got really mad.
Yeah,
of course.
But I'm cold.
Why?
Why are you mad at me for feeling?
Because it's a stupid field out of my control.
It's not grow up,
but I can't control how I was raised in La.
It's warm here.
I'm used to being warm.
It was ridiculous.
You ruined everybody's dinner.
People at the other tables were like genders being ruined and yes they did.
No,
you're the only one.
Ain't fucking stupidity.
That guy makes a lot of sense.
So he gets mad at me because of my,
my cold threshold is low and then we're driving in the car yesterday to the
country club.
It gave them all and you are showing me how you could sporty drive.
First of all,
I was not showing you how I could sporty drive a Jeep Cherokee with a v six like
a normal engine.
Nothing crazy.
Michael's car and the light turns green.
I turned,
we're going straight.
I hit the gas.
We hit 40 NAM.
Yes,
we did 46 and the the speed limit,
35 maybe 40 at the most in that residential.
And you go,
you're scaring me.
I was like,
what?
And you go,
you're scaring me.
I go,
why would you be scared?
Don't tell me.
Window feel fear,
right.
I looked and then he,
and then he gets mad at me for feeling fear.
Wait,
but why can't I be scared?
I mean you can,
but don't you think that's like,
well,
you got mad at me.
I hit 40 miles an hour.
Crazy.
It's crazy.
Or that you felt fear.
You've been in a car for how many years you did?
You were doing 46 and a 35 and you accelerated very quickly.
And we were by the mall and I thought,
you've somehow got to slow down to get into that parking.
Let me tell you this scenario,
if it were a kid in the car and the kid was like,
no,
the kid was like,
I was scared.
You'd be like,
all right,
you shouldn't feel fear because this is how cars move.
But you'd be like,
okay.
And then later on you'd be like,
Hey,
my kid's a fucking idiot.
Huh?
Yeah.
Like I'm saying is you,
were you really scared?
What were you scared for?
The feeling.
Listen,
I drive it.
Here's why 40 listen,
listen,
I drive a jeep Cherokee because I don't like going fast.
Okay?
But I was in your jeep.
Cherise it.
I'm driving to the mall and back.
That's my life.
I don't do fucking anything.
Okay.
So I like to drive the speed that I go slow.
I listened to my radio,
you know what I mean?
And then for you to get in my car and do your,
your,
your race car driving.
It was very tea.
I don't like it.
It's startling.
I like to go slow.
Listen,
let me tell you something.
I just renewed my license online.
Why?
Because I have no moving violations.
I have no tickets.
I have nothing.
I get that privilege because I'm a safe driver.
Yeah.
I thought I was going to get ticket last night.
Good.
I wish you would have.
Why to teach you a lesson about your sporty driving.
40 try me.
You almost got a ticket.
I thought I was going to get one.
Yeah.
Oh,
for speeding?
Yeah,
on the,
on the freeway.
But it was,
you know,
11 o'clock at night.
Okay.
Freeway.
Cool.
So we went to the country club yesterday and I'm walking around and we made a
few observations.
Number one,
we saw it.
We always make fun of that store as we walked by it.
The Tommy Bahama store.
Yeah.
I can't believe that that store thrives in this market for like 2030 years now.
My Stepdad,
my Indian step dad,
God rest his soul.
He's dead now.
He loved Tommy Bahama and he was a big,
big guy.
Like he was,
he got real fat.
Yeah.
And He loved it.
And it was official dad status of fish.
All Dad's dad is and that's really what Tommy Bahamas
all about.
Catering to the official dad market.
Yeah.
Cause like you,
you've pretty much given up.
Right?
If you're wearing like a Tommy Bahama Flora,
most disgusting friends who were,
who gave up a while ago.
But oddly enough,
if you have to give up but have some money because they're not cheap.
Is that,
I didn't know how much or how much is a Tommy,
can you bring up a shirt so we can see so the audience can see what we're
talking about in case they don't know.
It's like it's a very specific style.
It makes them really large cuts.
Right?
Isn't that the whole thing?
Is that the whole thing?
Well I have some really fat friends that wear them.
Oh look,
they have women's clothes at Tommy Bahama.
Oh there it is.
Now go back to that.
Oh yeah.
Look at all those big and tall.
Oh,
that's why.
Well,
that's why my step dad was into it.
Yeah.
Now it makes sense.
Those are dad shirts.
Go to the floor.
All that's like the tip of the Dad Berg.
It's like the button downs.
That's what my stepdad loved.
There you go.
That guy.
That's the official.
It's there.
There it is.
That's how I picture.
But how much are those shirts?
Fuck,
thank on.
That 100 and what hundred 40 you got to have your dad with a job.
That's a fortune 150 for that shirt.
No.
Yeah,
so you can't even buy it as a gag.
You can't be like
a shirt.
I know.
That's a fortune 101 60 oh my God.
Shit man.
Fuck,
that's Margaritaville.
That's the dad who's like listens to Kokomo and here's what happened.
You know,
you're 360 whatever pounds.
You're like,
I got to wear like a decent shirt.
They make you this six x,
you know,
and then you look like I'm trying,
I'm dressing nice,
but it really is a really bad patterns.
When you're fat,
it's,
it's even worse.
You got to go in minimalist molest when you're fat.
You know,
I guess I dunno,
but there's like,
you know there's outdoors.
He dads and vacation does vacation.
Dads want to look good and have fun even if they're a real fat,
you know,
I cannot get over the prices.
I have no idea.
I guess they want to price that one.
One 70 on the right.
That one.
Oh my gosh.
Shirts are terrible.
That shirt.
No.
Welcome to real world.
Spelled r e l with a like a sword fish jumping out the Tommy Bahama Lounge.
That's $170 the heck out of here.
God Damn sure fit for the o fit for the island life.
Yeah,
it's for vacation dead.
That's why they're dropping that kind of coin.
Banana,
I had no wait.
Let's see the size chart.
What's the size?
What's it go up to?
Four.
That's pretty big.
Yeah,
it's really a real dad.
What's,
what does that say?
Xcel
be?
What's Xcel be though?
That says,
yeah,
I'm not 100% sure what open the size chart be as big XLT is tall.
Ah,
look at the fitness guy here,
knows what's up.
I know the,
the voice of your run.
You just heard any works here too.
He's like the coolest hippest guy who wanted to buy him some time Mahama stuff.
But then we realized he'd make that shit cool.
Yeah.
We'd lose the whole point of the laugh.
Oh,
there's five XL on the bag.
Oh yeah.
But Hey,
I give it,
I give it.
You're right.
I like what you're saying that if you're GE,
you know,
listen,
I just ha,
you know,
I'm eight months now postpartum and when you're heavier than you normally are,
it's important to dress up even if you're in the process of losing weight or
whatever.
Um,
but really brought us to the point that,
um,
you know,
we were talking about,
I was telling you how I'm still kind of not in the body that I'd like to,
but I'm still losing weight and um,
and how everyone hates their bodies.
Everybody does.
Everybody.
I even,
I was in h and m and there is this adorable 20 something year old girl trying on
a shirt with her friend and she's like,
I don't know,
it just,
it looked,
I look fat and I,
and I said this towards like as a mom,
like I told them,
mom,
I was like,
I go,
sweet.
I've just,
I'm overhearing you.
You look amazing.
You're so pretty.
Just buy the damn shirt.
I said,
just do it once you say mind your business,
you fucking bitch.
But her friend was like,
see,
I told you.
She was like,
yeah,
that lady,
that crazy ladies,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Basically.
Yeah,
it's totally true.
I mean,
I hate my body so much and I try not to just dwell in it all the time.
Of course we all,
but then like my trainer who I work out with a few times a week,
last week,
he's like,
oh,
I'm doing a a 75 day challenge.
And I go,
what's that?
He's like,
you work out twice a day for 75 days.
And I was like,
why?
And he was like,
well,
just you know,
try to get an a,
I'll let kind of let myself go a little bit.
I was like,
what?
Like,
no,
you're the student body is amazing.
I see him in a tee shirt and shorts.
I'm like,
we talk at your totally ripped.
He's like,
Nah,
there's not like a used to be.
And I was working out twice a day for 75 days.
That's crazy.
And he's like,
you know,
I go,
do you notice any different,
cause it's been like a week or tonight.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
I've been taking pictures and we're talking like minuscule differences.
But to him and his mind,
what he sees in the mirror,
I don't know very few people I think go like I love my body.
I agree.
We all kind of,
I do now because I go like,
look what my body made.
It made two wonderful humans that we adore more than that.
Now.
I kind of really admire those people that don't have perfect bodies,
but you can tell they really accept their bodies.
Hey now I kind of admire that we,
how do we get there?
Is that,
is that,
I don't know.
I've talked about it in therapy a lot.
Your Ba.
Yeah.
And the solution.
It's what you think it is.
That's what it is.
What's that love.
And then there's people that I'm like your body and think that you're perfect.
You're adorable.
You'd like it hot outside.
I think I love your Toshi this morning till she's adorable.
I was looking at it.
Thanks Babe.
I love you taking berries.
Thanks.
Durable.
Yup.
Shoulders,
handsome,
nice shoulders.
That's when you know you have a ship body.
When someone was like your elbows,
they're great,
you got nice risks and you're like Eh,
good shoulders.
No one looking at your knees.
I've got beautiful knees but telling you wish you could tell your 20 year old
self.
Cause even when I was 20 and I weighed nothing and I was super skinny,
I still was like,
man,
I'm so fat.
Like,
dude,
don't you wish you could tell your 20 year old self like,
Hey,
you think you're fat now wait until you're 40.
Remember it makes me want to cry.
The time where I was a weight,
I had lost all this weight.
So I got really fat and then I lost all this weight.
I lost like 70 pounds.
I was in the best shape I'd ever been in.
And I remember I was on,
I was on a trip and I was with a buddy of mine and we were,
it was like a,
like a spring break kind of thing.
It was hot outside.
I didn't really know him that well.
Like I knew him,
but I was like,
I know how fair skinned I am.
I was like,
dude,
I gotta ask you something.
And then were in college to where I was like,
well you put this sunblock on my back cause I'll burn.
And he was like,
yeah,
I don't care.
And I was like,
all right,
cool.
He goes,
I mean,
why would I care?
Uh,
putting a sunblock on it,
some fat guy.
And I was like,
fuck.
I was like,
I fucking like no.
In my head I was like,
I'm still fat.
I just lost 70 pounds.
So I was like this.
So in my head I was like,
I'm still fat now.
Now that was like,
fuck,
I was 21,
you know,
and then when asked me if I was pregnant yesterday and that felt good to know.
No,
you walked her into that one.
She didn't,
she didn't understand what you were saying.
You're like,
you're like,
oh,
I just had,
I'm having this baby.
And she,
she had,
she understood I'm having this baby and then she was like,
oh,
you're pregnant.
Okay.
Whatever.
The Nail Lady,
we asked me if I was talking to that lady and she's four and you know,
foreigners,
they don't know anything.
She was heating up or curry in the back room.
They don't even speak English.
Go fucking sleep outside.
You tell her that once you do my nails,
just shut the fuck up.
Don't you love that we have this show
telling us what we can and can't say.
You know what?
F Mcdonald's.
Okay.
So,
um,
you know,
I did,
um,
I didn't,
I don't think,
I don't even know if I mentioned it before on this show.
I actually did a set in Spanish last night.
I know,
I'm so proud of you.
That must've been so hard.
It was,
it was something I've always wanted to do.
Like I've been wanting,
I've wanted to do this for years.
I've always done little bits of Spanish like at night in every special,
but I think I've done it in to where I've mentioned something you're cursing or
you have like a fire.
I'll tell like one story that involves the fact that I,
you know,
was raised speaking Spanish and I'll,
I'll do a bit,
but like,
you know,
we're talking of an hour show one minute or something,
but I always was like,
oh man.
Cause Spanish has been,
or saying it's been getting bigger in Spanish language countries the last few
years.
It's really starting to grow.
And I'm always like,
I wonder if I could do a full set in Spanish.
Yeah.
So fuck,
sorry.
I've been talking to a couple guys about it for a few months and they're like,
yeah,
we do it every once in awhile.
And I was like,
yeah,
I want to do it.
But I was kind of like,
you know,
hesitant.
I was like,
I don't know if I can actually do it.
So anyways,
a few weeks ago,
uh,
Francisco Ramos hits me up.
He's like,
we're going to do the show.
Do you want to do it?
And by the way,
he's great.
He's great,
nicest guy.
And um,
he's like Ricky Ricardo,
like the guy has got,
yeah,
that Kinda,
he's got the Hollywood energy about him.
Yeah.
Very positive.
Very funny.
And he's like,
do you want to do it?
And I just,
without even thinking,
I go,
yes,
I want to do it.
And then I was,
and then I see them put the poster out like the Flyer and I was like,
Oh shit.
Sabado Domingo.
Yeah.
But I'm like,
this is real.
Now that there's a guy in clown makeup,
but he'll have to write really big bets for Allie.
We did the thing.
So they put the these guys,
I guess they do it.
Semi-Regularly um,
so fuck buddies.
Eco Cabana is a Chilean comic speak Mexican.
This dude,
he already,
he's like,
uh,
actually to me,
I love it.
He's white.
Married you.
Why don't you Latin it up more?
You know,
I love Puerto Rica.
Haim and Hayes was Trey.
Hello Trey.
Hello.
Name Francisco Ramos,
Eh.
So anyways,
they do this show called a trifecta.
We did it with a,
I think who else was on this show?
Fuck this guy.
Hot something Colombian guy.
Richard via Philippe's.
Parsa he's been on the show by your mom's house.
Okay.
Did it also last night anyways,
we sign up to do it.
Show sells out like in the first day.
Was that the lab?
And then,
um,
and then I'm like,
Oh shit,
I'm writing this stuff.
And then I'm,
I'm basically having Francisco helped me.
So I would send him my jokes and he was like,
you should say it this way,
not this way.
He's translating stuff for me.
And then I'm like,
I actually,
I,
I realized that I was having the same feelings for this show that I had doing
stand up 17 years ago.
Like when,
uh,
17 years ago when I started doing standup,
you,
we would book,
you know,
you'd have like first you'd have one show a month,
let's say you'd go,
I'm doing stand up next month.
And that's it.
That's your show for six or eight weeks or something.
And as you get closer to that show,
you're writing things out like full length pages and you're reviewing them and
then you're starting to get like you're editing.
As you get closer and you're getting nervous and you wake up thinking about your
show it,
you'd had so much pressure to do that show.
And I don't have those feelings like that obviously and more because I've done
it for this many years.
But this Spanish show was kind of close to that where,
I mean I didn't pop out of my sleep,
but I was like walking around and thinking about how am I going?
Cause you have to think about like,
you don't get any reps in Spanish.
So you don't know like,
yeah,
what's gonna work?
What's not gonna work?
What's gonna happen as far as timing and saying the punchline the right way
anyways,
it went great.
I had the best time doing it.
Good.
I'm definitely gonna do it again and um,
I don't know.
I had to,
I had a great time,
so I appreciate those.
Got It.
How do you,
you say things that you know,
you just translate your current act,
so you're alleging
two things.
I did things that were specifically just for a Spanish language audience.
So I wrote material just for the show and then I also translated some things I'm
doing right now into Spanish.
Tried that.
Do you ever think your wife's a dumb bitch?
Yeah.
Something like that.
Like is your wife angry you with how cold she gets?
I ain't going through this process on a bow tie
and
stuff like that.
I love it.
I lay way about what does that mean?
Yeah,
give her that nut.
yeah,
yeah.
I'm so excited about the Spanish Tom.
I like to see more of Spanish.
Tom.
I Spanish.
I was going to be working it out more it I think so.
Hey tacos in my pocket.
I be mad.
The do you like the Tacos?
You liked that Patheo or Cholula.
Is that what you're going to open with it the next time?
Maybe.
You know what?
I was funny.
I did that show last night.
At one point I asked who in the audience had kids and like one tablecloth and I
was like,
what the fuck is this?
A whole rumor.
People at one table has kids.
How's that even?
Right.
It's never,
that never happens.
All they do is fuck.
Okay,
well I mean that's very problematic.
Shit.
You're fucking from the fifth grade.
That's really what's up.
Well,
you've said that before.
The growing up in Florida,
especially in Miami,
that was a different culture.
Very Miami.
You're like,
I have a Pokemon.
And they're like,
do you finger girls too?
And you're like,
what?
I'm an elementary school.
And they're like,
so are we man,
it's Miami.
They're really crazy that at least they were when I was growing up.
Yeah.
The first time I was sexually harassed,
I was like a 11 or 12 and it was like this Latin dude I went to school with and
he was like,
he goes,
damn girl,
you got a though just won't
quit.
And I was like,
oh 11 and I was like,
what?
I don't even have a body yet.
You know what I mean?
Him was like,
all right cool.
I got my kids on
wearing a training bra.
Oh my God.
Friend of ours,
comedian,
writer,
director,
producer,
choreographer,
entrepreneur,
long overdue vessel.
A vessel,
sovereign citizen.
It is,
I haven't tried to join a fake sovereign country wants out of a magazine.
I can just remember that there's this art magazine,
I think it was called cabinet.
And they did an article about like areas where that were like specific enough to
where like someone had formed a fake sovereign country that you could,
and I sent like my fucking social security number basically to somewhere in
Australia cause there was like a building where one of the floors was considered
a sovereign country and you can become a citizen of it.
And I was like,
do it and and I didn't get anything in an email.
Can you send a check to,
no,
it wasn't any money.
I just sent like my info like can I please become a citizen of this fake
country?
But then you have to pay taxes to them.
No,
I think that was the whole,
I think that's why people do it is to not pay taxes.
I love,
I'm a country,
you can't charge me shit.
a country.
That's where they tried to do in that wild,
wild country where they were like,
we're our own state or city or whatever.
I also realized that like at a certain point if enough people said they are,
you kind of would have to acknowledge it,
right?
Yeah.
We have enough people say anything.
Eventually you're like,
fine.
Yeah.
That's how it words get defined.
They're like,
well,
what the word means?
No,
it's not really a word and then enough people say it and it becomes a word is a
word.
It is now.
It wasn't a 10 years ago.
I swear to God.
Now back to the most important thing at hand.
Right before we started rolling here regardless.
Go ahead.
Rip Freddy Soto.
Rest in peace.
Ready.
So ear regardless,
one of the great bits of all time.
Is that what I'm about?
His Dad,
his dad said Irregardless is that would be the bit was about inserting that word
places where it didn't belong you,
but he'd say it all the time.
It was great.
This is such a great bit.
No.
Yeah,
but you brought up a really good phrase.
It's like I've been waiting my whole life for somebody to say it the way you
just did.
Out of context singing.
I hate it.
I fucking hate it.
To give you an example,
some people that can sing think they're blessing us all the time with their
beautiful voice.
So you're in the frozen food aisle and you just hear Ah,
shut your damn mouth.
I didn't ask for this and might run in bed or hold on,
let's stop the West Slang.
I bad.
Was I at Gelson's?
Yeah.
Day sever peoples was whistling along with the music and I it myself,
I was like stop it.
And so I stopped.
Yeah,
no,
but here's what I hate too,
is like you're watching a talk show and the,
the young ingenue was there and the host goes,
oh,
you're a singer.
Sing us something.
And then they're forced to sing without any music or any preparation.
And it makes me,
I can sing.
And that was pretty good song.
I have a good voice to go for it.
Go tell me.
Do you like it?
I hate that it makes me so uncomfortable.
Then the person has to sing on cue.
That's like someone,
like,
I'm a comedian,
tell me a joke.
And you're like,
that was literally the worst,
the worst.
So I was in the,
I was in the hallway at the comedy store and some lady was talking to the person
next to me and she goes,
are you going on?
I said,
yeah.
And she goes,
oh,
so like,
what's your act?
And I wanted to joke just was go,
I go,
I tell jokes.
And I looked at her in a way that told her,
you're wrong for what you just did.
Yeah,
yeah.
How'd she respond?
She was like,
ah,
yeah,
you call her stupid cat.
No,
he kind of could have,
I said it with my eyes sag after us.
The worst is a so what,
what's it all about?
What do you do it?
What's it like?
If I knew that I wouldn't be here if I had a sense of what anything was about,
I wouldn't be here.
Right.
Yeah.
I wouldn't be clawing at the walls of approval.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Worst is the way that question is the worst.
Also,
what do you go up there?
I don't want,
who wants that kind of stand up at this point?
Like that kind of perfectly encompassed bumps,
severe of,
of your,
of your persona so you can then sell it to NBC.
I'm so past anger of being asked that question now for like so many years that
now when I get asked,
I swear to you,
I just got asked.
So you're,
you're a comedian.
Yeah.
And they're like,
what do you do?
I go,
I don't really know.
By the way,
that is a true,
yeah.
And the perfect answer.
I Dunno.
I don't really know.
I don't really know what I'm doing.
I don't know what I'm doing.
98% of the time that good and I wouldn't go.
It's weird that people let me still and um,
I don't know why I've done it for so long and I wake up confused almost every
day.
Yeah.
All right.
And they'll probably be like,
me too.
We were like,
Oh red,
what are you do Kevin?
What are you acting on these days?
You're always acting on some nothing.
Why are you talking about,
Oh I think the last thing you liked masters of sex.
God Damn it.
And then I got,
yeah,
I fell out of it just cause we got so busy with the kiddos and life and stuff.
But you're so fantastic on that.
That's nice of you.
Thank you.
Yeah,
thank you.
You're done a bunch of cool stuff.
I'm lucky I've done I,
my,
my look fits squarely into a category,
so I've always been lucky that they need someone who looks like they can work on
machine.
It is,
it is weird to live in this town for this long and you're just flipping through
channels.
Sometimes you're like,
Holy Shit,
I know that guy.
Yeah,
like shows like Hey Scott.
Yeah.
Yeah it is.
It's weird that like I don't watch any of my friends' shows and I'm like,
it's just,
it's become all of our jobs.
So you're just like,
oh cool.
Like I only know my friends are working when I called them.
They're like,
I'm a New Mexico.
Like oh okay.
Like that's how you find out.
She was doing something very rare that I've fallen in love with his show and I
loved a masters of sex.
It was,
you know,
objectively it was a like I can say like that was a very good show cause I
wasn't there from like I started like halfway through the first season so I was
able to watch it without me on it and a,
I was like,
Oh shit,
these people are good.
I better try hard.
And for those who don't know it's about Johnson and Johnson it now.
Yeah,
they studied people's sexual habits and such informed masters and Johnson
masters in jobs,
but then it became Johnson and know that's something that's different people,
whatever.
And by the way,
everyone does that,
but I googled it.
I fell and whatever,
but they just pioneered sex research.
There you go.
They map the female orgasm,
stuff like that.
So Nice.
Right down between the legs.
That's the stuff that goes on.
I've heard about.
I flick it
to check on
juvenile as we are.
Some guests come in here,
just turn you off right here now
that's good too.
This is all good.
Stuff like that.
And then you go like that.
It's so similar to when a Nintendo game would freeze.
You just blow on it
now.
Now do we get married?
That turns you on so nasty to you.
Nasty.
You love that Puerto Rican stuff.
My husband just did his first sentence Spanish last night and brand new.
So I feel like I have like Rockin Espanol,
Csun,
young Spanish lover.
Now you should wait a minute.
You've never role played.
You've had of Spanish speakers his entire time and I've never had him say,
let's do this in Spanish.
I wish
mature baby,
least dose at least like hit her
like standing naked in the corner.
What's the Mexican fantasy?
The Mexican fantasy.
We're predominantly Mexican.
Like what's the Mexican fantasy for you?
What's the role?
Oh,
you're obviously the lady at home and I'm like the gardening team and I just
come over like this.
See,
I know that seems like obvious some of your like racist assumptions.
But for me,
what's August?
You're a successful,
it's third generation business owner in America long enough.
And then you get to play the role of like the poor white woman who's coming to
you for help.
Whoa.
You put her in a little jail jail.
I liked the guys coming in all 30
the code for the gate,
they can get in
the sprinkler,
no working music.
My husband will be home soon and he's like,
he's so gay.
I come fast.
That's not a good pitch.
I can't be part of anyone's France.
Like there's a rush,
go,
go.
And then he's like,
okay.
I mean,
or something like six guys come in.
Okay.
It happens.
It's like every time you're facing away your heads,
your head's in the trash.
And then every time I do a new accent,
he keeps saying it's a different guy.
Do you ever wonder what the small talk is like between guys at a gang?
Bang.
Yeah,
yeah,
I do it.
There's no way.
There's none.
Right?
He's gotta be so there's no way it's all about the gang bang.
Right.
So at some point it's gotta be like,
maybe do you think there's like a circuit?
We're,
those guys go to more than one.
So I was like,
Dude,
you're looking Jack,
do you working out?
Like he notices definitely Steve Lost Weight.
You look great,
you look great.
I think there's things about shoes like,
oh yeah.
Oh that's the big,
got a guest.
The floor slippery.
Yeah.
No,
that's a big thing.
Like you were like,
that's why,
you know,
they're like,
hey man,
you don't want to be walking around this site.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're right.
We should wear galoshes.
If I even walked near a Gangbang set,
I would have a hazmat suit this hoses out on like I'd walk in hoses on.
It wasn't that crazy to have that.
You're always all like you and all these guys kind of always stroking and
talking.
You're like,
yeah,
Lakers are fucked up this year.
Hunt and you're just strolling in with Lebron.
They got nothing out there like literally did not make the playoffs this year.
One guy's got to work his nipples.
Yeah,
yeah.
Needs it.
He's got a job to do.
That's right.
That's not really true.
Let's talk about your body.
It's a perfect segue to his body.
We were just talking about how much we hate our bodies and how everybody,
Hey,
but even people with gray bodies or bodies almost like maybe they hate it more
because they become more informed about what it could be and where they're at.
You hit yours too.
Oh,
oh girl.
See,
I look at yours.
I'm like,
this guy's got,
he's got a
cool tattoo.
I've been trying,
I've been trying now for six months.
Like,
I just thought the other day I've been going to the gym five days a week,
probably for six months just to look,
just to still hate my body and only look okay from like 50 feet away in closing.
That's not bad.
It's not bad,
but still closing over a certain age.
That's the whole goal.
You're never going to look good naked over for your doctor drew who like
apparently well that you have to,
he's been doing,
he is checked in a couple places.
Ah,
good to see it.
David Goggins like that guy.
Like that guy is like
former seal and fitness,
former yawn.
Um,
he runs like darker rules a day.
Fascinating.
Like I learned so much at an early age from that show.
Like any teenager love line level line because he grew up here in La and if you
listened to k rock,
right?
Sunday nights.
Loveline was that Sunday night?
Yeah.
Forman and doctor drew everything.
Uh,
but did you know that we have a podcast,
Dr drew after Dark Fridays at noon.
Oh,
okay.
Fun.
Be Fun.
He's a smart guy and the like all those damn kids yet errors.
What?
Oh,
Fridays at noon.
If those kids are like,
we'll probably grown up now they are his children.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
How old are they?
College age.
Weird.
Yeah.
How many are there?
Three.
Yeah.
I had triplets.
Three to send to college at once.
I know it's crazy model sometimes too.
It gives you get extra money.
If doctor drew became a male prostitute,
he'd do well.
Oh my God.
He could do one of those themed cruises where like you go and you pay and you
get to like rub oil on him.
Yeah.
I feel like you know a lot about this.
Well,
there's all those weird themed cruises now.
That's a great,
yeah.
You guys can do a cruise.
This cruise.
The doctor drew oil crews.
I don't know.
I made it up.
There's enough obscure cruises now to,
that would be a fine one.
Do you want to rub oil on this guy?
There's like Star Trek cruises.
I would rub oil on doctor drew would be my po.
Who am I to not want to considering what he's given me and the rest of the world
cause true am I haven't done anything to say I shouldn't be excited about
rubbing some oil to make sure he doesn't get burned.
He could be a prostitute for women.
Like real.
Yeah.
Both.
I wonder,
I'd love to see that.
I would love to hear about this kind of standards.
What,
what women stupid who want a male prostitute are looking for either west
Juggalos.
No.
Well that's really good.
Is that a real thing?
How bad is it?
Scripted or real?
It's like a semi scripted but it's like it follows a real escort agency.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
But you can tell that the girls are looking,
so the website has different genres of dudes.
Like if you like the sensitive ponytail guy who says no mas de Yoga,
there's him,
there's the tech boy,
Kevin Christie of the crew base.
And then there's a smart sensitive type,
which is the Kevin Christie.
No boy
cause it's worth it.
You guys hear the argument in my head,
you guys think the sensitive guy is really just one of the hopes right there.
John was he in that body is crazy.
Yeah,
but I,
but he was on,
cause I follow him on Instagram.
He was just on Instagram being like I'm on a new diet,
go to get my abs pop.
That's it from people I know who work out a lot to look like that your entire
life.
It's a commitment.
It's not calling it and it's your job.
You are pretty miserable all the time.
I mean I follow all these,
my Instagram's sucks now because I fall a fitness thing.
So like my explorer page is just fitness shit dude.
Cause it,
you know what it was,
I was in pain.
Like I have a weird back.
The pain clinic.
Yeah.
And so I've just was like,
I'm tired of hurting my back doing nothing.
So I was like,
maybe if I,
if I exercise it'll get better and it has kind of yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Cause as your,
where's your back page with lower back,
lower back pain.
Like I hurt.
I hurt my back while ago.
I don't even know what I did.
It just all of a sudden it was like I heard a sound and I was like,
oh,
here it goes a week.
Like you lose a week or two of your life every time it happens and pass a
certain age are like,
this is bullshit.
I hurt my back playing football in fifth grade.
Like I slipped the disc.
Yeah,
in fifth grade and I still,
yeah,
of course.
No.
I had went and got and Mris and everything and they're like,
oh,
you have spot any live thesis of the fifth lumbar third degree and ever.
I mean,
that means I'm 10 years old.
I guess when that happened means you have to become a third degree.
Black belt can fix it.
Oh Dude.
It's still,
are we taking taekwondo guys or what?
Let's get it.
Let's do it.
It's still a gives me problems.
Valley taekwondo.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's Siri and you don't want to get back surgery.
You want to avoid that shit at all costs that shits.
No.
What I did was the doctor told me,
he's like,
you know,
if you'll just like get fat and not work out.
Yeah,
it'll be feel much.
Congrats on nailing that.
And he was like,
then you'll feel better.
I mean I spent so much time like hunched over a desk and I see what like old
artists look like.
I was like,
I don't know if I want that.
Like it just looks painful all cause I didn't realize every time you see an old
person walking slow,
it's not that they're old.
They're in pain.
Well missing head.
You've seen that dude.
I saw a guy,
this guy was walking in front of me.
I swear to you.
This guy,
this is real.
Oh yeah,
the is bent.
So like hunt so bad.
The head's gone dude.
But this,
I took this picture.
This isn't like from the Internet.
They're okay.
That to me doesn't even look that bad luck.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying man.
So bad that his low self esteem personified.
That's a,
that's a,
by the way let,
that is a life of looking down so you don't want to face the world.
Which I can understand.
And then eventually over time he trained all his muscles to look down coupled
with a few fifth grade football injury.
So there's no,
there's no narcissists that are,
have that problem,
right?
No,
no,
no.
Mom was good self esteem.
Nah,
I thought it was the iPhone.
Maybe he's using,
oh my friend Leslie told me that plastic surgeons are of having to fix,
there's a new double Chin situation when people always looking down that people
are always like this.
So there's a lot of people getting tightened up,
tightened up and you can't grow a beard like
face banks.
I don't think I made that up.
I think someone else do face banks are good.
Yeah.
I think with the tats though,
how many of you got,
man,
have you ever wanted to get like a,
like a white supremacist one and just see if you can get away with it?
Wanted to get one.
You can't see my back
because if you told me like I don't know what any of those are,
you could tell me like,
you know,
Aryan Brotherhood.
It's cool man.
Oh you don't know.
You know like the one that the secret ones,
just like 13 words or whatever.
Right,
right.
The secret ones
catch your,
just won't get them and also no wait.
Tattooers won't do,
a lot of them will do them.
You got to like find,
find like a brother.
I got a guy,
I know a guy.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that'd be unfortunate.
When you have a change of heart,
you know like you get out of the there,
there's a program that actually were removed those for free.
Oh yeah.
I watched the thing about it,
like how much to give them out.
Gang gang members get out and they're like,
Hey,
can you take this thing off my face?
Or like,
yeah,
we can't like swastikas.
All kinds of just like that.
Could you imagine?
Oh Dude,
I want to go back to this day.
I want to have those guys and be like,
what was the day like?
Really like put the swastika like,
well you're,
no,
you're in the day was you're in jail.
The ARYAN Brotherhood.
It's like you're going to die if you don't do this and you're like,
fire it up.
Here's a good spot right here.
Right in the Hindu,
it means peace,
right?
Yeah.
Sorta,
sorta.
Also,
there's this Chinese guy at lunch,
we need you to stab him in the,
yeah.
Okay.
Welcome to the club.
We have jackets.
They still,
I mean,
I guess they still do,
but of course they do.
I'm guessing there's a recent spike.
Oh yeah.
But I actually,
I don't,
I,
uh,
I mean I get it.
You've got to have something to look forward to when you're locked up,
but you gotta have you gotta fill the day.
Got To have some fun.
I really,
if I went to prison,
I realized that's a probably be how I would get by as tattooing people
that would make keep me safe is like a good draw naked girls for people to jerk
off to and staff's trail.
How terrifying is that day when like you're in prison,
let's say you're in there for some bullshit and then they're like,
you're white,
you're in the brotherhood and you're like,
okay,
no,
you have to be like,
yeah.
Basically you have to be like,
Or you have to like go to like the child molester wing to be safe.
I don't want to do that.
No you don't.
Here's our brother.
Kevin haven't go ahead and you're like,
well what about you?
You got that sticky last name.
Oh I know,
but I'd be like,
no,
I'd be like,
I would never let that out.
Now
let's say they watch your act.
I love your stuff.
I wrote it.
I took Spanish in high school man.
Look my blue eyes anyways.
Anyways,
yeah,
it'd be awful.
Yeah you get,
cause they would be like,
that'd probably be the worst if they're like you're a happy,
that's what I'm saying,
cause you can't go with the Latins and you can't go with the Lens would not
accept me for,
they would not let you in at all.
The white,
the white guys would let me in for a while.
Especially if like the thing is I could just go deep.
I'd be like fuck it.
Spics and just keeps saying it.
And then you also have money,
so like you could help their drug trade and you get a lot of money put on your
book,
if you know what I'm saying.
Put on your book.
So you'd be,
you'd be heavy with them.
Snacks
handing out those honey buns.
I don't mind.
I don't mind man.
Sign me up in the women's prisons.
Is it that I was not as hardcore?
No,
I don't think there's,
I don't think there are.
There's gangs,
but I don't think there are.
I don't think it's as,
they're not as violent either.
Sisera and all day.
That's true though.
The documentaries.
I've seen women hookup quick.
You get a prison wife,
your wife up to,
I'd have to find a nice lady to take care of me and protect me.
Yeah.
But they just,
yeah,
they just let bow out.
You wouldn't want to turn it turn a bitch up though.
Yeah.
I mean you want to be someone you want to get turned out.
You don't want to like go in there kind of heavy and be like this is actually
going to be,
and then you pick one.
I don't know how I,
now I,
I just tried to hide that thing where you,
they talk about prison and they're like,
oh yeah,
you got to fight the first day.
I'm like,
oh no.
We're imagine like also the guys like you're beautiful code and you're like,
I don't,
he's like,
yes,
we are.
All right.
Yeah.
I'm parties.
Like,
okay,
will you not beat me?
He's like,
yeah.
Like,
Like is it me?
Maybe he's gonna happen.
Right.
So my rationale was like,
don't hit me in the face girl.
Like,
like,
and let's,
let's come up with some rules.
Okay.
Here's a good question for you.
Yeah.
You get to pick,
okay.
If you got to pick,
okay,
there's some dicks coming into yourself.
Want to get it right in the mouth or in the ass and the ass.
Why?
Why in the ass?
Right up to see less of the dicks.
It's less personal and your ass.
Yeah.
It's less personal in my butt.
And you'd asked for a lube,
right?
Uh,
yeah.
I asked for it.
I would insist on it.
And could you guys start off with some fingers,
like kind of warn you that privilege in prison though these guys are picked,
but you may get a nice neck rub.
Yeah,
true.
At the same time,
uh,
bad though.
All bad.
Also crazy that you also might get aids.
Yeah.
Maybe.
How'd you get age?
Like these four guys?
Yeah.
No,
but they could use the slim Jim condom where they just take the wrapper off the
commissary to,
they're not going to use condoms.
No,
no,
no.
I didn't feel as good.
Oh,
it feels good.
Especially the guy with age.
He's like,
I want to give this guys.
Yeah,
but what about these guys that are lifers?
Like,
you know,
we've been watching love that that's who's doing it.
I know,
but you'd think that the prospect of getting but sext but raped would,
um,
deter you from wanting to go back.
But apparently it's not that horrible if you keep going back and back and back.
I mean it's,
it's,
I think some people are just used to the horror donated to that culture and that
becomes your lifestyle and you get good at it.
The real world's probably pretty terrifying if you've been presented for over 20
years.
Can you imagine going out there and like,
here's your smartphone.
Like it'd be awful,
truly awful.
And if you've developed some,
and it's not like you're going to get out of prison after 25 years and someone
was like,
here's your cool job.
No,
like your life is going to be a real bummer if you don't have a family that's
looking to help you,
you're fucked.
You know what I'm saying?
So you just do it.
You just pop a crime and go back.
It's violating parole is very easy.
It is.
And it,
at least you know what to expect in prison.
Yeah.
You know what the deal is?
You know how to get by.
You know how to survive in the real world.
Yet that becomes a world.
And you know how to navigate Getty Wednesdays.
Oh No.
I mean,
I don't know if that's a real thing,
but we gotta be Wednesdays are real.
It's is it okay?
Is it that far from elementary school?
If you just get to sleep there,
you slept in elementary school.
Look,
I lived in fear of violence in elementary school every day.
The food was terrible.
If I,
if they were just a cot and I only have one or two outfits.
How that's the difference.
My parents were kind of hands off anyway.
What city were you in?
La Crescenta.
Okay.
It was a nice helmet.
I don't know.
Prison has another level though.
Right?
But the handball tournaments,
we're cool.
Yeah.
And I would,
I'd have,
I would have gotten in shape so much earlier in life.
Well,
that's what everybody says,
right?
You work out like crazy all this time.
But the nutrition's poor.
So I imagine
it's difficult when you're not eating well.
You're not on the Keto Diet.
Sure.
You're not getting enough protein.
But I mean,
you're working out a lot.
You are slim Jim.
You know,
you might actually get that body.
You've always wanted it in prison.
That's the big trade on both parties have always wanted.
I'd be in good enough shape to get a cute looking guy.
He's got a good body I've always wanted.
Yeah.
You know,
I can look at myself while I'm myself.
I wonder if you're like,
you would morph if you'd be like,
Nah,
I pretty much love guys.
You know?
I think the human brain's pretty malleable and you make the best out of where
you're at.
I think so too.
It's Steve,
someones hottest girl at the bank.
A cigarette.
If you work at a bank,
the hottest girl in the bank is the hottest girl in your entire world.
That's true.
And in prison world,
it's your world.
It becomes your world.
Yeah.
I believe it's called situational homosexuality.
Sure.
Oh,
I have been down that path.
You were saying earlier too,
you're like,
what would it be like if we were 20 years?
I imagine if I was young now would I have like face and neck tattoos?
Probably in today's world I started getting them in art school,
so I would be like,
how's how high up?
Do you have a tea?
Well,
I don't have any.
They're all in my arms to be fair.
I fucking despise getting them.
They're so painful.
I hate it.
Really?
Some people are like a dick.
I don't.
I think a,
that's bullshit.
And I also am not one of them.
Like they're like,
I love the paint.
I'm like,
oh cool,
can I poke you with a needle just because we're standing here like that seems
like bullshit,
but I hate,
that's why I don't have a big one because like I can hang in there like an hour
and a half,
two hours and then I'm like stop it.
Okay.
Oh it's awful.
After a while it gets a little less painful.
But you sweat because you can't move.
So you're just sitting there,
you're natural instinct to flinch.
You have to like word it the whole time.
They not give you any kind of pain blocker.
I don't know why.
It's like why don't they have topical anesthetic?
That's really,
really good question.
I'll put dude out man.
Well cause they do for like removing moles and shit.
Like they just put a topic I get.
Yeah.
Every time I get something taken out of my face to give me a shot,
it doesn't hurt.
They saw it off with a razor blade.
So why am I sitting there pretending I'm like tough enough to be in a biker
gang?
Just cause I want something done.
Put on my arm.
I don't know.
Do you regret any,
any of them right now?
Yeah,
I have some regrets.
I have one.
Uh,
I regret this.
A Cleveland Brown's helmet.
Why do you have that?
I was a,
I loved the Cleveland Browns for a little while when I liked it.
I just don't really like football anymore.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Just because of how it's evolved.
Is like,
as I've gotten older,
just like corporate sports,
he's just like,
yeah,
it's kind of gross.
How,
how big the corporation of the NFL is.
Yeah.
I just like what they do to the players,
the way the players are treated after the fact I don't like,
yeah.
You're just kind of abandon these people and you just embraced the browns at a
certain way.
We didn't,
we,
this was back when we didn't have a team here.
Right.
And it was the year the Brown's got their team back.
I just thought it was like a nice,
I used to make some exciting moves,
man.
Yeah,
they did.
They did.
It doesn't matter to me,
but I know I'm going to probably turn that into a book or something.
Really?
I Dunno.
Something something funny.
They'll only tattoos.
To me,
the appeal at this point are like funny ones,
like something stupid.
It'd be funny if you made an a that's taking a shit.
That'd be funny just to have on a flight and someone was like,
what's up dude?
You're like,
this is lady taking the very first.
The very first tattoo I got was from this guy I went to college with.
He worked at a tattoo shop and then I heard rumors that like,
oh yeah,
if you get a big one from him.
I heard he hides drawings of shit in it like as a prank and so I never went to
him when he would hide it for a while he was doing this thing where you could
come to them and get,
if you were willing to get a a Martini glass would shit in it.
He'd do it for free.
Oh my God,
that's great artist.
This guy mark hedge,
he could draw his fucking balls off.
He's,
I think he's still a tattoo artist in Detroit.
Is that by the way,
cause you're awesome artists.
Is that an innate,
do you figure it out young?
Yeah,
it is.
Right.
I was able to draw drawing at a young age and like Brian,
my cousin can really like just naturally withdraw,
you know,
a face and you're like,
wow.
And then I would draw and look like I dragged my feet or something.
It was just like,
yeah,
I could always kind of do it.
It's weird to me that people can't actually find it strange.
Well because like you guys can write letters,
you can learn,
you can make an r look like an r.
And to me it's like the same thing kind of really.
But it doesn't,
you do.
Is there,
um,
have you ever seen like some of these hyper real,
yeah.
Can you do that?
Yeah.
Really that's an issue of time.
Hyper realist.
They just,
what they have as an a kind of patients.
That's insane.
And a lot of you have to understand not to be addicted,
these people,
but a lot,
you know,
there's a lot of tricks to really,
well you use a graph or a projector to get like the base structure,
right?
And then you just spend,
oh it's a documentary called,
I think it's called finding Maryland.
It's about a guy who spent 10 years doing a hyper realistic portrait of Marilyn
Monroe.
And it was his big plan to become a famous artist.
And guess what?
It didn't work.
And I mean he p he drew it like less than an inch a day,
like a square inch.
And his big plan was he knew a guy who knew a guy that knew David Hockney and
see was going to show it to David Hockney and that was going to like start his
career.
He spent 10 years,
like 12 hours a day.
Well thought out.
No,
no,
not at all.
Well thought out.
Good documentary though.
What else happens in prison by the way?
I gave him the grease and I tell him now I'm on his finger
sticking in his eighties and you know what I'm saying?
Kind of like fuck you sell to loosen yourself up.
Yeah.
Cause I know he ain't never been penetrated before.
It was just first time just the old penitentiary trick that I learned from some
old convicts.
If you scream rape,
you know what I'm saying?
He had grease on his fingernail so he agrees his own self up.
Isn't that cool?
It's really interesting.
That is equal parts romance and safe and thinking about your own safety.
Yeah.
And engineer.
I mean think about what he's saying there.
For people who don't follow,
they,
they get a guy in a silo.
They tell him to put grease on his finger and stick it in his own ass.
And then if that guy was like,
those guys fucked me.
They're like,
Oh,
you've been greasing yourself up.
This dude not only planning,
he planted evidence and sensuality at the exact time and that is a rare person.
See what?
That's such a waste that that guy's in jail when he could be out running a
fortune 500 guy.
By the way,
I went into the vaults film studio.
I mean,
he has the mind of a Hollywood executive Weinstein Weinstein or this guy that
just got fired from Warner brothers.
He was,
he basically was like,
Hey,
I'll give you a part multiple.
It's in a movie,
this one lady,
and then they boned.
And then there was,
there's some hilarious text messages.
Those were great where she's like,
um,
you said you'd help me.
What?
Remember when you were inside me?
Like,
oh,
cool.
And then,
uh,
did you see her music video?
No.
It's really funny because,
uh,
I saw the article and I went to her video and then people were like,
pro tip,
hit mute on this video because it's just her like dancing around in lingerie and
her voice is horrible.
Right.
And that guy even references her video and one other texts too,
if,
yeah,
I don't understand why people that rich can't just go to escorts and stuff.
I know why toy was like starlets or how about this?
Why can't that dude,
who's the like just meet attractive women all the time and bone and like not
have it tied to an audition.
Partly.
How is it that,
cause it's not creepy.
It is not the pay off the field.
The power move of like the wind like Oh yeah you're you're so hot.
Like you,
you need me.
Yeah.
I'm so cool that I've got,
but you're also so rich.
Can't you just impress people with your power by like going on a yacht that's
the ultimate rich guy pulled like want to go to Paris on our first date.
Like isn't that the move but you're that's like the kind of growing one has a
girlfriend.
He just wants to bounce.
Right Tom?
Yeah,
but I'm saying like good at all this stuff.
It all,
but I understand that too.
Like if you just want to bone also like that's what rich guys,
powerful guys do.
They're like I just want to bone.
And usually the influence of your power and money or enough to be able to bump
that would make actually me feel uglier that I know they own.
If she brought up like,
I'd love to get in that new movie,
I'd be like,
you don't really like me.
Yeah,
of course.
And that to me,
I,
it'd be,
I'd already be worried about that and be feeling that.
So the minute it got confirmed,
I'd be like,
you know,
thank you Max.
Able to,
I would have done this,
I would've done this different with this girl.
What I would've done is she had been,
she shows up and you're like,
yeah,
I'm down.
And you're looking at her and you're like,
let's do it.
She's like,
you know,
I really liked to be in a movie or something.
I'd be like,
well,
you know,
send me that,
uh,
that real on Monday.
And then you smash that night and she,
and you're like,
send me that real.
And then she sends the real and you're like,
yeah,
this could take some acting classes.
So you kind of like put her down and that makes her want to impress you more.
So there have been working on my acting classes and you're like,
how about those blowjob?
You were working on those.
And then she comes around,
polishes you off again,
send you another real and you're like,
yeah,
go back to class for both,
you know.
Have you ever thought,
have you ever thought of pitching to lifetime as a show?
Just like as a movie.
One of those like Christmas,
Walmart,
a word.
By the way,
the guy,
he's not like gross looking.
No,
he's like very handsome dude.
Yeah.
Well put together.
I'll put together,
look like he was in good shape.
Beautiful Skin.
Like what exactly?
Best Diet.
I fuck the,
I would fuck the Warner Brothers Guy 10 times before I Fuck Tattoo guy.
Yeah,
but here's the deal.
Here's where she messed up.
There it is.
Oh yeah,
he's a cute little now he's cute.
Yeah,
me.
This guy can't find my,
she messed up.
The whole always takes the money first.
You don't give it up and then expect the guy to pay he to pay first and then you
give up the goodies.
Paul says half the money before I leave the house house to Miami,
La second hat before I go on stage.
Okay.
That's what I'm talking about.
So she fucked up her damn self.
You fucked up your money.
That's right.
You can take a business course.
You get the,
you get paid.
You could put,
hey
stupid.
That's her fault.
Listen,
if you're going to be a hoe,
at least get the shit first.
And then she was like texting like you remember when you were inside of me and
hilarious.
Hilarious.
I just,
it baffles me that these rich guys can't figure out a way to get to get this.
I mean,
like I said,
I probably a lot of them can,
you know,
there's the ones that get caught.
You're like,
you dork.
It's always dorks.
Always Dork.
He's a door.
They cannot dorks dorks.
We're not prepared for.
And shame.
There's enough young,
attractive chicks out there who just want to be in that scene and words.
The jet setting party scene who are not like,
I'm a,
I am trying to act.
Oh,
without a tradition.
That's who you should be with men.
Here's what the girl you need the girl who just wants handbags and shoes to go
to the elite party.
You know what the problem is?
He's so rich.
He lives in hangup,
hangs out in a group and in an areas where those,
he can't find women that are just stoked to on what he has.
And in pray you're around people who standards are so high that unless you're
getting them a movie,
he's only meeting actresses.
The only young and an old rich guy always wants a woman that's too hot and too
young for him.
And the only women like that he's meeting are actresses that's put,
that becomes his thing.
Like those are the ones these aiming at.
They always want something to,
yeah,
the wants gotta be very low.
It's like the manager dating the client can,
that's a bad thing.
You don't want the person wanting from you.
It's so weird.
No,
I'm drinking my water.
Thank you.
Open.
It is already finished.
Mine's already been open.
It's already been drank from go get your own water.
No you cannot.
Come on.
I'm so thirsty.
Give her some water.
I know.
He's so selfish.
Jesus.
You only,
wow.
Wow.
But now it's got an impressive,
so you didn't finish it.
You Bitch ass nothing.
There's two sips in there.
That's why he drinks that.
That's why he took it.
Cause it's not even really drinking water.
It's two sips.
You're so selfish data.
The collection that is the opposite of a finger with grease on it.
Kevin,
you're a lady now.
You ever been angry at your lady for her being too cold and needing to turn the
heat on?
Stupid though?
Look,
there is clearly a temperature difference in every couple and every one was a
fucking stupid Jesus.
Can you hear that accent?
What's going on,
professor?
Oh
the professor from Gilligan's island.
But yeah,
for some reason I,
I've never been the same temperature as anyone.
And you run hot or do you run good?
I think,
I think I will.
I'd never,
I sleep and just underpants.
Yeah.
So we would go,
we would be good.
Bunkies
I will say the only thing that bothers me is when someone's like how the air and
you look over and they're just sweated up.
Like they have sweatpants on sweat shirt on in bed under a cover and I'm like
take some of your rope as off and remove Europa's yeah.
Do you have on [inaudible] right now?
Remove the cow and then we'll talk temp.
Well,
here's mine.
Here's my point.
We were at an outdoor restaurant,
patio dining.
Why?
Well it was,
it was,
it was a nice day out.
Okay.
Oh,
during the evening was upon you and they had a heat lamp and I was nice and
toasty under there and he was p became slowly and rage.
However,
let the record show that Mr [inaudible] was wearing a hooded sweatshirt and
could have removed the layer.
Got To remove your layer.
But no,
I don't because listen,
she had them,
we'll over.
It wasn't necessary.
The sweatshirt was appropriate for the natural temperature.
She's like wheel that over and you know it has settings basically cranked all
the way full crank it all the way to anchor my husband.
Yeah,
Dude.
Like it's like,
it's 20 degrees outside.
So then I'm like,
just turn that down.
It's ridiculous.
Take your sweatshirt off.
No,
turn the oven off.
Right.
There's no point in horseshoe booth.
And he was sitting next to me in the sweatshirt.
So I said,
okay then just as word islands
or go over here instead of cross.
But isn't this such a beautiful testament to your relationship,
but these are your problems I guess.
Yeah.
These are not big bays are not watch one episode of cops.
Right.
It's like he took a shit in my car.
I'm like,
these things could be way worse.
That's true.
I told him to get new needles and he did it and fucking dirty ass needles.
Now I got HIV mother fucker.
I'm like,
there are people,
that's true.
He hits my kid but I can't hit his kid
when they do the same.
They were both setting fires in the backyard and I slapped mine in fucking then
he slapped my butt.
I can't slap Hez cause she blind.
There could be many worse things.
Do you hate your woman for her temperature needs?
Very rarely.
I mean,
and she sleeps nice and heavily.
So when I like,
you know when you're like leap out of bed off,
that's like adjuster.
We're like,
motherfucker like she doesn't notice so I don't get held accountable for that
angle.
If you were to drive faster than she likes.
That only happened once and I slowed down.
You slept.
Oh,
interesting.
You didn't tell me the sooner I didn't get angry at her because the wait,
what did you do?
I don't remember.
I think I just,
I think,
I probably guess,
I think I just going away on ramp and you're like,
oh,
we can't do fifth 46 and a 35 I think I just maybe made a turn.
I,
you know,
I overestimate my own reflexes.
I think I make left turns a little closer to a car coming towards us and she'd
prefer,
because again,
she's passenger side,
so if we get broad sided,
Kevin walks away,
dead girlfriend.
So I think she was just like,
oh,
like a little like that.
And I was like,
oh,
I want to do that.
I just didn't,
I,
there's very rarely anyone in my car.
She was like,
don't do that.
Yeah.
She didn't even have to say,
don't do that.
The,
the,
the visual of her grabbing the door.
It wasn't enough to me be like,
don't do that.
I didn't do anything like that.
He made have you made a left turn very quickly?
You accelerated into the turn and then he did 46 and a 35 you were going very
fast and I had to hold onto the handle.
Oh,
you'll
add to hold on and brace myself.
Well look,
if you're going to get a car that he bought a fancy car that's fast.
You got to a Jeep Cherokee.
But here's the,
here's the deal man.
Those are quick mom card.
You know the problem with a Jeep Cherokee is they feel kind of loose cause
they're up a little higher like shocks.
When when the,
when the Jeep Cherokee takes off,
you feel like you're,
you're on a roller coaster a little bit.
I like it.
Okay.
But there's like someone likes living dangerously when she's in charge.
Thank you Kevin.
Again,
this is,
I think the point you're really trying to make
the Kevin,
he got angry with me for feeling the fear for expressing the fear.
Oh,
see I don't,
you can't get out.
You can't get angry with how someone feels.
You can get angry with how they react to that feeling.
Yeah.
I don't think you agreed with what I just said.
I think he's just said.
Yeah.
Are you adjusting a fantasy team on your
like
10 times a day?
Oh,
for fuck's sake.
So there's this a news piece we wanted to just show you couldn't believe this
made it into the news.
I got a screen in front of me with your two screens.
I remember,
I remember you guys just hosting it like the Irvine Improv for some Shitbox,
you know,
showcase.
Everyone was poor.
The parking lot at the comedy store is so funny to me now.
Just like Tesla,
Tesla,
port port,
Fourchon corvette,
what are used to be just like someone getting walking.
They're like,
whose bike is that?
I love it though.
It's quite hilarious watching someone get rich from talking about there.
But
my favorite like crazy.
No know,
but like crushers,
gold,
Rolex.
I just,
I just think it's a butthole Rolex cause he literally got a gold Rolex talking
about a particular lot of shoots.
I go,
I was like,
dude,
you paid for that talking about your Dick and nuts and pass.
And he goes,
Ooh,
talk about wanting to put oil on somebody's.
Okay,
rob,
you're on your man.
Good.
Good Morning Julia.
This is your why m h exclusive Florida man report.
I'm your host Pete Melfi and I'm someone who slowly letting go of the delusional
reasons why I even bothered manscaping anymore.
Our final story tonight for demand,
Brett Krishna,
who is widely known as a racist and child Predator and it's also fat as fuck
balloon to his highest weight ever.
This week we reached out to Mr Kremlin for comment and his response was,
quote,
I can't talk right now.
I'm eating.
He then humbled illegible words with his mouth full and ended the call by going
on an antisemitic rants about how the Jews are suppressing.
His number's on here.
That's about all the time we have left for today.
Remember to get your Florida man updates by following on social media at fl.
Man,
report this on me.
Beat me.
I'm home here now.
Until next time.
This is Pete Melfi saying try it out.
Wow.
That was a nice man.
Burn the news.
It seems like all his fat goes forward but not sideways.
Yeah.
So from the right angle,
you're like,
like I go more sideways than forward.
He's an alcoholic and that's it.
Easy on it.
Why is that common?
Yeah,
I thought that's more of his brand.
It's fine.
It's totally fine.
Can you imagine if he was sober and still looked in back at?
No.
No,
because when he doesn't drink,
he's,
he leans out pretty quick.
Right,
Tom?
I mean it's really,
it's wild.
He has one of those by,
you know,
it looks like a car,
like a manatee swelling up and it's almost like if you were,
he died a month ago.
Yeah,
it does.
It looks like a dead person and then he can literally eat clean and sober for a
week and dropped like 15 pounds.
Amazing.
Yeah.
And you think you would?
Yeah,
it's,
it's self imposed
again.
I,
but I will say when I go to my gym,
I don't know,
I'm usually there with a bunch of other men in their forties and there's a look
on all our faces,
like,
why are we doing?
Like,
what are we training for?
War Can we were just talking about like it's just the state of hiring.
Like not the person that pretends the person who is really like I'm fine with
with what I got.
That's fine.
Yeah.
I think it's just the like I don't want to have to make fashion decisions based
on yes,
bad.
Like when I started having to buy new pants then you're like,
oh man,
some depressing.
Very depressing.
Like when you're giving away clothes.
I went and bought jeans once and there's this Eh,
this company where you could,
you could return your cool looking beat up jeans.
They give you half off a new pair.
And I was returning a pair and getting a sense of,
because yeah,
most people were turning for this reason.
I was like,
what do you mean?
He goes,
oh just like dudes in their late thirties who have like,
you know,
need a bigger sign.
He just said we're at all.
Cause I was like,
yeah,
I need to,
I think I need a 34 and the ones I was turning and we're like a 31
oh,
so you've given up.
Yeah.
But I agree.
Like I've resigned to the fact that my body's,
I'm never going to look the way I did in my twenties but I don't like that
decision too of having to dress around your fat.
That's worse.
I've realized I've never gonna like possess agility.
Like I can't do like physical things.
Like I see people,
Jim like jumping off on a box and I'm like,
no ma'am,
no ma'am.
But if I could just like not have my pants hurt,
I don't want my clothes to hurt.
Yeah.
Cause I don't.
The other day I was like picking something up and I made a noise and I,
and I thought to myself,
I don't even know that I need to make a noise.
I just now do it.
But like when I bend over to pick up a quarter,
I go and I don't even know if I'm feeling that noise or I'm just now,
that's the what I do when I pick something up.
I don't even know if it hurts.
You know what?
I don't,
I don't want to run up the stairs and feel that tire.
Yeah.
That's the one I,
that's not like,
oh,
I'm sure I don't want to die of a heart attack and a staircase.
That too.
That'd be bad.
Yeah.
I also don't want boobs Gig.
Get a Bra.
I don't want to like,
I don't want,
I don't know.
I'm vain,
I guess.
Yeah,
we all are.
Yeah.
And I,
you know,
it definitely looked worse than you look worse than when you're young.
I don't care what you're doing and your face is your face and your elbow.
Skin tells the truth so you can't,
there's certain parts of your body like,
I don't care.
I go to the gym every day for the next four years.
There's still gonna be parts of my butter.
Like,
what's up dude?
Who's in his forties for sure.
Like I don't care.
And let's,
let's be honest,
your Dick is just a fucking lie detector tests all the time.
Your junk tells your age.
Yeah.
No one has new looking nuts.
Like you can't,
there's no,
there is literally not a machine at the gym to tightens up your scroll.
That's true.
No Way.
That just looks tar up,
right baby.
Two babies and it does not look the same as it did years ago,
but looks alone is terrifying.
It looks nice.
Extra parts to it now.
No,
no,
no.
It looks nice.
It doesn't look.
It does look nice.
I'll settle this show.
If you were Puerto Rican,
she'd fucking drop her pants right now.
Is that a real thing?
You have a thing.
Puerto Rican.
What about them?
I like the way they want in life.
No,
I liked the culture.
I like their swag.
I liked the aesthetics.
The by Londo that constant by launching the byline.
Living lives.
Yeah.
I don't have any exposure to Puerto Rican men.
I don't know how they're the best.
Go to Miami,
Bro.
I went to Miami once and let me tell you about who hated it.
This guy,
there's nothing I,
I as far as like not your jam is,
you could not pick a place less than I'd want to go to.
I could see that.
Yes.
I could see you hating.
Oh,
Vegas sucks.
I liked,
actually I kind of like Vegas in my twenties because I like playing blackjack.
Really?
Yeah.
And like I was young enough to where strip clubs didn't make me sad over a
certain age.
You,
I could not,
I couldn't separate myself from like the sadness of a,
of a strip joint past like 26 I was like,
ah,
that bruise looks,
do you ever go and do you ever try to go make them sad?
Come,
I
can't be that hot.
Just telling them about my girlfriend's job and she's like,
hey.
And you're like,
why are you doing this?
Yeah,
when she's like,
just putting myself through school and I'm like,
are you though,
like how long have you been saying like,
are you really going to be a nurse?
Yeah,
I don't think so.
I feel like you're not used to normal hours.
Like imagine how low somebody has to go to do what you're doing.
Yeah.
Like let me ask you this,
cinnamon,
is this the last rung on the ladder or do you feel like there's one below this?
I used to always think about,
not so much now because pornography is so such a huge business,
but in the 90s like people getting turned away from doing porn.
Imagine that day.
I know.
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm here.
Let's do this.
They're like,
Eh,
I don't know.
Yeah,
you can come on my face.
Yeah.
And they're like,
we don't want to though.
Oh God,
that'd be a whore.
You're not good enough.
They're all those documentaries in the 90s about like getting cast as a porno.
You had to actually try out for things.
I wonder if that's still a rule.
I don't know.
I feel like,
but now with the Internet though,
anyone can upload their own thing,
so maybe somebody else doesn't want to put you in something,
but you can record and be like,
Hey,
here's my,
I hate amateur porn.
Really what I want to watch high school basketball.
Fucking sucks dude.
Then I will say the nice thing about porn on night,
last 20 years is the guys finally got in shape.
Oh yeah.
Cause they looked so gross.
It was just not believable.
Like no one's fucking that guy.
Give a,
do you have a genre?
You get into uh,
enthusiasm.
Yeah.
That's sad.
Just like the third technique is called mouthwatering good.
This tech,
they can each blow job because it's very important.
This is what you're going to do is you're going to take his penis and push as
far back in your throat that you can to gag when you gag the mouth waters and
your eyes here.
This allows you to know that you're doing it correctly.
This is a bummer.
That's what bums me out.
I've heard of that lady.
She did our podcast,
uh,
years ago.
I mean I'm glad she's out there doing it but also don't.
So no amateur stuff for you.
Nah,
I don't.
The lighting is terrible.
There's always like one angle and by the way,
you want to talk sad.
These apartments they live in.
That's actually the thing.
It'll take me out during the day.
So there's a blanket over the window and you're just like,
you see like the stack of DVDs and you're like,
why are you still have DVDs?
It's never,
I never feel like amateur porn is the woman's idea on any level.
It's always a dude who's dating a girl too hot for him.
And he's like,
come on,
I'll be so rad.
And then 11 years later when it's still on the Internet,
this poor lays like God damn.
Cause you imagine just watch him.
They always have the worst tan lines.
Like the dude's,
there's no,
there's no care.
There's just no care and anything about them.
Their pubic hairs,
a descent amateur stuff too is like the guy really doesn't know what he's doing.
He has a row mediocre Dick.
He can't fuck well,
doesn't know about angles.
He's certainly,
yeah,
it's certainly not picking her up.
There's nothing interesting about him.
He's like a dude that,
you know,
it's like,
I'm going to see him at the open mic.
You know?
I don't want that.
I just want people that are better looking than me.
100% people who look like me doing stuff.
Yeah.
It's like I want the CW of porn.
I want beautiful people or stupid and that's,
yeah,
yeah.
Although I liked nineties born just because there was no future in it and I was
like,
these people just want to fuck.
That's true.
It did feel,
you're right,
there was more gravity to being a porn star in the 80s and that was a decision.
You are either addicted to coke or you just couldn't stop boning.
Dude,
why don't you get into making something that's dark,
so dark?
I can't,
again,
it's the same thing as like owning a strip.
Okay.
I will tell you this.
In like two,
this is probably 15 years ago,
I watched a special,
I watched real sex on HBO and there was a guy on it,
this,
uh,
he was a gay porn director and a drag queen,
I think.
And he ran a voyeur house for gay guys and all he did was set up cameras all
over this house and he was making 1,000,007 a month and subscriptions and I had
a little money time and I was like,
oh are we doing this?
Like what do I just rent a house in West Hollywood ragged?
I figured like getting it would probably cost you 50 grand and then just offer
free rent to hot dudes.
Oh yeah,
like hello,
I want you to do this now.
I think probably that ship has sailed because no one pays report anymore.
But he said he's like,
he's like our subscribers cause you could type in what you wanted the guys to
do.
He's like,
they don't even want to watch them have sex.
They're like,
take off your socks,
take a shower.
Like simple things like real life stuff.
And I was like,
this feels almost victimless and I would love that money.
Yeah,
of course.
But directing like porn porn like,
hey could you do it again and like look more scared.
Like that seems like,
oh,
then you're like,
I'm going to come in my pants.
What qualifies as porn now it's like fucking cheat.
It just seems like evidence and like a long running investigation.
I refuse to believe this.
Many people want incest porn.
Yeah,
that is a huge show.
Feels like it feels like,
I always,
I think there's like in my head there's like a meeting of like what kind of porn
should we make of the industry?
And they're all like,
how about people boating who are attractive?
And then was like,
good idea.
And then I feel like there's one guys like brothers and sisters are like La,
Hey Scott,
we're x.
But that's not,
it won't shut the fuck up,
but I wonder it's gotta be popular.
You gotta gotta be,
they release,
they release those things.
Usually if there's like a report,
you know,
I think yeah,
hub will be like,
here's like the five most popular search terms and it's by region,
by country and you'll see what's big and yeah,
there's incest.
They love that incest shit man.
I've noticed they rename like clips that aren't,
they'll just name anything like stepsister.
It's like gnats plumber.
That's plumber scenario.
They're trying to get you to click on.
Yeah,
it's so weird.
So you know what you can,
you can obviously coincides with those divorce rates.
Just shooting through the roof.
No one would connect to it unless everyone had to step siblings.
It wouldn't be a thing even thought about rose.
I like a boss scenario.
A boss.
Yeah,
someone's in charge.
Someone's not power.
Power dynamic.
When I was younger and I watched more porn,
MILF was always made sense to me really well.
Just like someone,
it seemed again enthusiasm.
You liked that granny stuff too now.
Oh there was a figure model at my art school that was legitimately old.
Like she was like 85 and an 85 year old naked woman is more of a sculpture than
something you want to touch.
But how much do you get paid for that at art center?
I think you got paid.
Okay.
I think you've got like a few hundred bucks cause it's a long,
it's a seven hour class.
So to sit naked for a bunch of kids who are laughing inside for none of us were
laughing inside.
I would,
I would never be able to be an art student cause I would giggle.
They'll really,
everyone was serious.
You'd be surprised.
I actually thought about this.
I noticed even some of the models were beautiful people.
I never once got aroused cause you're my brain can't try to figure out how to
draw something and w and think about it sexually at the same time.
It just doesn't happen.
But by Cox you see some Nice Cox.
Oh yeah.
I've told this story before,
but it was a long time ago.
There was a guy who modeled at Pasadena City College.
He was a dancer.
His name was shadow and his Dick was no joke.
11 inches soft.
And like a Pringles can like one time an old,
like there's a lot of,
there's a lot of older women who take like a figure drawing classes at junior
colleges.
One time a woman came in late and saw shadows Dick and dropped her art Ben.
She was like,
it was,
I would tell my friends about it.
I was like,
there's this dude and they didn't believe me.
So one day I just drew it to scale and like brought it by.
I was like,
here it is.
They were like,
it was unusably large and that's what I'm thinking utility wise and I'm almost,
I don't believe shadow was straight.
He was rail thin like he was,
he was really cool looking.
He had like really long dreadlocks and more like these cool scars and he had
this cool like Cain you would kind of stand on then Lena.
But this thing was shocking.
Oh weird.
So it was a black guy with this big,
yeah,
it was shocking and,
and but again like really impressive but it wasn't,
it's just you're really just drawn shit.
Ever do that thing where he like smacks in the other hand are,
he's like,
no,
but he fell asleep once it moved
while he was doing a later post.
He was doing a laying pose.
It didn't like get hard.
But it moved for sure.
And you know,
I was like a lizard.
I wasn't close enough but I bet you could hear it.
Yeah.
Just like you heard,
just like
the people fall asleep a lot when they're getting drawn.
Only if they're doing it like a laying posts.
Like sometimes you do like an hour in a painting class,
you'd do like a long pose all day,
like a three hour pose.
So data really be a pain.
The figure modeling is incredibly difficult.
Like people don't,
I think a lot of people try it to stay in the same position.
First of all,
no one can stay in the same position for more than 20 minutes.
I always move a little.
So you're always,
you got to hurry up and get the hard parts like the face and shit cause they're
going to turn.
But like a long pose,
they always picked uh,
a position that was basically sleeping cause you can't stand in one position for
three hours.
Your body gives,
I think people would fall asleep in the leg,
they'd fall asleep.
A lot of them.
I mean you usually do like 45 minutes or like 30 minutes and they get like a
five minute break,
but still even that,
but they would get in a position that was really comfortable.
I would be nothing but sleep.
They'd be like,
Oh yeah.
Hey Tom.
He says like,
you're snoring.
Everyone's fucking
the snoring.
Oh God.
Did you hear stories sometimes?
No.
No one ever.
Oh wait,
no though.
Yeah.
There was one old guy,
he looked like Santa Claus and he would not often snore.
It was pretty cute.
Yeah,
that's me.
But he was such,
he was such a beloved figure model because of that big beard.
He was so easy.
It made him so easy and fun to what was his package like?
It wasn't good.
There was only two guys,
I don't know.
There was three guys with decent packages.
There was shadow shadow,
but he didn't model it arts center,
which was kind of a bummer.
He had modeled at art center,
not figure modeled.
There was a professional x dancer who was Latin and he had a good piece and a
great buy and then there was a guy that kind looked like a bodybuilder and he
had a decent piece.
He was a good,
those guys were all really good figure models.
This now I go to one,
I go to like a figure drawing workshop.
There's never any dudes,
because I think it's all,
it's all women who are like kind of dancer.
He looking and I think it's because they probably pay like a hundred bucks and
like you kind of don't want a guy in the room who could take 100 bucks for
getting,
she's probably literally insane.
Yeah.
So I would like to go in there and just get on my knees,
bend forward and spread the cheeks and be like,
draw that.
I mean you'd have to hold that for like seven hours.
It's amazing.
The lack of weird things that happened in a room with someone randomly naked.
Really.
There was only one when I was in school,
there was this guy who was autistic,
but a brilliant artists like he could draw crazy.
Good.
And he was a little strange and I guess he was staring at the model just like
for two in a way that was weird,
like in between poses and she was like,
please stop staring at me.
Yeah.
And so he was a weird dude.
So he put a bag over his head and cut like I holes in it.
And then they had to kick him out of school.
Sound guys,
one of the students?
Yeah,
Jesus put to watch this guy draw was amazing because he would,
he would like,
so he'd be drawing maybe to figure model there and he,
he would go like this,
but he wouldn't be touching the paper and then you just go and it'd be like the
perfect line.
Like he'd be like,
it was like watching a sword fight and you'd watch this dude.
Right.
And you could nail it.
It was incredible.
But then he put a bag on his head and had to leave school,
but he was just creepy and just a little off.
Yeah.
And he could really only figure draw.
He couldn't like do other stuff.
There was a lot of like,
art school is full of people that are a little left to center,
but whatever.
Thank God there's so much Dolores.
You do?
Alright.
I drink so much water.
You wouldn't know what that's like.
Oh yeah.
Here's another one that's not another one.
That's the same way.
I'm just see you had like two ounces.
You're like,
I gotta pee me.
I drink like 20.
I'm like,
well my body's just getting started.
I don't,
I think I tried not to drink water because I don't want to be going to the
bathroom all the time.
I know,
but you have to hydrate,
hydrate code.
Where can people see you?
The comedy store?
I'm there every weekend.
This weekend.
No,
I'm,
I'm with Whitney this weekend in DC.
She's taping her special.
You're going to open the special?
Yeah.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Congrats.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Are you guys doing any like shows like the night before,
two nights before?
Uh,
there's like a,
there's like a run through the night before.
Before the taping,
but I think everything's sold out.
Some Whitney,
Cummings.
Sure.
She got fans.
And then after the mini store.
Real Nice.
I'll be inside you.
So some respect.
Oh yeah.
That story.
You can find me on social media,
Kevin Gee,
Christie,
hilarious comic.
Go see him at the store and go see him anywhere.
Um,
seriously.
See me in the market?
No anywhere.
You can see Kevin Christie,
you should,
he'll draw your dick in the checkout line.
Yeah.
If you bust out your cock,
I will say I K I am.
Look,
I brought a sketch.
I thought you could draw the whole staffs ticks here.
Oh,
okay.
That's a great idea.
Dick Detective.
Yeah.
Oh,
in a lot.
If by the way,
if there was a lineup I could pick shadow out till this day,
and that was 20 years ago,
you know,
if we can put a call out there to shadow I,
dude,
I've mentioned him before.
I wish I could find him.
How old was he then?
He was probably in his twenties.
Oh,
so he's still out there.
It's probably swinging that thing around.
I mean,
there's no way.
He's not in demand in some region because of that.
Magnificent and his body was incredibly,
it's probably six one probably weighed 120 pounds,
God and six pounds of it was dick
and he was so nice.
What'd you guys talk about it and breaks and stuff like shadowed man.
Jeez.
You know my friend Travis went to junior college with me and we were like,
Dang.
It was like,
dude,
are you not talk about his day.
It'd be like if there was a fire in the middle of the room and not mentioning it
like someone just like lit off some mad.
He's like,
how do you not notice that shadow cock?
You're a hater if you don't mention it.
That's true.
If you don't mention it,
you're a hater.
Like,
Hey,
we just saw the most beautiful piece we've ever seen.
That guy is telling John Holmes to take a seat.
Okay,
okay.
You basically,
you realize you're telling like,
uh,
you're,
you're setting the scene for stories will be told for generations.
Right now.
People are out there like licking their lips.
Thinking about Shar Pei again,
just all right.
Just picture in Puerto Rican.
Kevin Christie,
everybody.
Thank you very much for Kevin.
Kevin,
thank you for coming for
coming in my com.
Kevin,
we'll be back to talking about photos and Dick's after this quick break and we
are back and this is a real treat.
We've been wanting to plan this for a while.
I am joined.
We are joined now by comedian,
writer,
actor.
He does it all.
George Perez.
Hey,
what's up my boy?
What's up dog?
Excellent.
Thanks for coming over.
Thanks for doing this man.
Not Thank you.
I'm excited.
I've been running into each other for a while.
Yeah.
He hooked me up with a gift last time I saw you.
How'd you like that?
Yes.
This life man.
It was uh,
it was pretty,
I mean why don't you tell her about it?
I gave him weed and it was called puppy breath.
Cause like when you smoke this weed,
everybody was,
oh my God.
Your breasts most,
okay,
so it's,
yeah,
it's my boy bzz t biz and it was,
it's solid.
Yeah,
that's the weed I smoke only really elusive.
that FirstClass Canada.
That's it.
I like it.
I like around when it comes to lead,
it's like whole foods for me.
I only buy the organic shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
Fuck all that.
Fuck that man.
Are you a,
you're doing shows all over now,
right?
Yeah.
I think the first time I ran into you,
I ran into recently,
but I still feel like the first time I ran into you,
it might've been with like a couple of these Chicago guys.
Are you friends with any of those guys?
I feel like I was,
I remember,
I remember the first time I ran into,
it was right after I did Rogan's podcast.
Wait a minute.
That's not the first time though.
For like remember me and you talking.
Really?
Yeah.
I remember seeing you at,
uh,
like you were with a group of guys and I was at a show,
like I'm talking
a long time ago where,
what city here?
Somewhere in La.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I know a couple of guys,
but Chicago,
but not like maybe they were with other Chicago guys maybe.
Maybe.
Yeah.
And so,
wait,
when was the Rogan One?
Not that long ago.
I did it like three years ago.
Okay,
okay.
Yeah.
And I remember watching you guys on it and they asked you and goes,
do you know George Perez?
And you were like,
yeah,
no,
that comic book artists and I laughed my ass off.
I said that.
Yeah.
Cause there's a guy named George Perez that draws for marvel and DC.
Oh.
And he's bald headed like me.
It's weird.
You have an amazing story.
Oh,
it's pretty fucking crazy.
I remember the first time I heard this story,
I was like,
this just sounds not true.
Like just
the fact that like there's a comic and you're doing,
you're doing things and you get on TV.
Yeah.
And that this leads to prison.
I mean she doesn't know.
She doesn't know the story.
I purposely did not want to get the deals.
I was like,
here I got the first time.
You'd please.
Okay.
So I stopped gang banging.
I have a son,
but you know,
you're still gang banging.
But I'm not out there.
I'm not looking for trouble.
Where are you from?
First of all,
everybody knows,
oh,
from orange.
Okay.
And I don't want to say the,
I still got shit to say.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
And then we use around it.
Let me just to like kind of give it a,
some color.
You're surrounded by gang bang and as a kid,
right?
Well this is 1991 bro.
Okay.
Everyone's gangbanging.
Yeah.
Like,
I don't even know.
I'm on the,
I'm the captain of the football team and I'm gang maiming.
Really?
Yeah.
It's just like I,
back in those days,
nobody moves.
So it's everybody from kindergarten.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's all my friends.
And then we decided to make our own game because our family wouldn't let him be
from that,
from their game.
They're like,
you're not going to be for this.
Fucking gangs were like,
all right,
fuck it.
We made our own.
Really?
Yeah.
We started as a party crew and then we're like,
you know what?
We're going to parties and people are trying to beat us up so my friend decides
to bring gun and we're like,
all right.
No,
you're a gang.
Yeah.
I didn't know you could start your own gang.
Pretty crazy,
right?
Yeah.
No,
you can pretty DIY of you guys.
It's pretty,
what's that?
Do it yourself.
It's pretty punk rock.
Yeah.
I'll say that in the gang.
Like,
hey man,
we're DIY.
That was pretty bad right there.
Dyi Diy.
Do it yourself.
Yeah.
What you're talking now or the
best thing about,
I guess all all gangs,
but the thing that always grabs people's attention are like nicknames.
Yes.
Oh yes.
Smiley did chorus joker.
I'm shocked.
Shocked.
Yeah,
that's me.
Right.
That's a dope nickname.
Cause like when I got jumped in that,
first of all,
I hit drop seq of foot drop and then I got dropped.
It was just boom,
boom.
And they're like,
hey,
that's shotgun right there.
I like that.
That's tight nickname.
Hell yeah.
Yeah.
Back in the days to the girls who'd be like,
what's your nickname?
Or they call me shotgun baby to Cox and you blow your kid.
I can't leave.
I've never said that on fucking stage.
You saw that shirt?
No.
That's a good church.
That is a good shirt.
Yeah,
man.
I know.
I grew up here.
I grew up in San Fernando valley and my first friend was a chola named Shula and
she taught me how to smoke cigarettes when I was 13 and she will know how to
smoke cigarette smoke from Chula.
And she was like,
Hey,
you want to hang out with my friends and I?
She goes,
you like oldies?
And I was like,
fuck no,
I don't like fucking oldies.
Like I like Morrissey or whatever the fuck gay shit.
I was listening to you what I mean,
but did you listen to oldies,
Haley?
Yeah,
I grew up on that shit.
You know what Cholos grew up on?
Morrissey.
Cellos do grew up.
There's a story.
Yeah,
there was a story that,
I guess he was going to Woodstock somewhere and his bus broke down in Boyle
heights in east la and they're out there fixing the bus and all the Cholos came
and he was like amuse high.
Everyone's hair was slicked back,
the wrong crease down.
The women had roses and they made them food and they gave him heroin and he was
like,
I'll fucking staying here.
That's good.
I'm trying to find out if that's true.
Cause that's bomb.
You notice he caters to East la?
No.
Yeah,
he caters to East La.
He does shows downtown La.
East La.
Really Morrissey.
Yeah.
So oldies,
oldies were always just on,
right?
Angel Baby.
Yeah.
Oldies and funk.
But old these were on because like the culture for a Cholo is to love and
protect your lady.
Right.
Our lebows the man,
dude,
I got to work with him.
Fuck yeah.
It was crazy.
That's cool.
Yeah.
But you know,
by the way,
did you ever know that that the,
the term,
the word so low is in some Spanish speaking countries,
very derogatory.
You did know that.
So I've met like some Mexican people here and like,
you know,
in,
for people that don't know if you're like California and it kind of describes a
certain culture and a status,
right?
Yeah.
But like in Latin America,
Cholo is like in some places like Edward.
Yeah.
You know,
and it means it's too,
ah,
nevermind.
It's a,
but it's,
it's a,
it basically,
you would say it too.
It's kind of native.
Yeah.
Native.
It's kind of worse than the n word.
Yeah,
it's pretty bad.
Cause like it's weird.
I've always had this argument,
my mom last night,
I was dating,
my mom was like,
I didn't come to America for you to be a fucking Cholo.
I walked for you to be a Cholo on.
I was like,
dude,
why you put this on me?
It's like fuck my bad.
You know what I mean?
But it is looked upon bad,
but it's only looked upon bad because they seen it as we were bringing them
down,
not realizing Cholos were created to protect the community.
Right.
Because white people in blacks would come around and our community and try to
punk us and take what we had because they didn't want us there.
Right.
So the Cholos mate,
they became the protectors and then smile.
Now cry later.
Fuck yeah.
So,
okay,
so how does this crazy right here?
I love this.
Right now I feel like I'm on like CSI,
but like you guys are cool lawyers.
So
all right,
so you're,
you're in this,
uh,
you know you're growing up and you're in this school in this area where you guys
are like we're,
we're our own gang.
Yeah.
Well it was a party crew and loot.
We're right next door to Santa Ana,
Garden Grove,
orange fooler 10 and it's like activeness yeah,
there's a street that we cruise that's called Bristol and I've seen people die.
They're like f at 14 years old.
I seen people get shock and I fucking come back the next week cause there's bomb
ass chicks,
there's everything.
And Yeah Bro.
That was the lifestyle.
And then boom,
graduated high school.
Kemet construction worker did telemarketing.
I did all kinds of shit.
I bet you like you a pretty good employee.
Like when you sidewalk.
Yeah.
Cause I'm just like show up to work on,
you know,
we have those comedic skills that we didn't know about.
So I didn't know back then I used,
I was like,
I had work that was like kind of poor.
So I had to make fun of you cause I know you're going to make fun of me.
I borrowed shoes on my tools.
Yeah.
So fuck yeah,
but you showed up on time.
Oh fuck yeah.
I called early today I suspect to see everybody suspected this though.
Yeah.
Cause you have that thing where I you,
I believe that you're going to do what you say you're going to do.
Oh I will.
Yeah.
Fuck,
that's crazy how you asked me that.
I felt like you were asking me to kill somebody or you know what George,
I can say what you do.
Well actually off Mike,
I want to talk to you about something.
Don't listen.
He's a good guy.
Yeah.
All right.
So I'm trying,
so how soon app,
like you're working in construction you to do with construction.
I got two kids now dog at this point.
At this point I have for now.
How old were you when you had your first 18 yeah,
so now I've got an 18 I'm 18 I'm 19 I got no 20 I get my second babies.
Mom pregnant.
We,
we were good.
I do construction and then we break up and I meet this other chick and not the
girls I've been with are not educated.
But if I meet an educated chick,
she's uh,
trying to get her master's in creative writing and she's like,
Hey homie,
I don't know if you know this,
but you are a comedian and you don't even know this.
I was like,
the fuck you talking.
Really?
Yeah.
So she took me to report,
you're reading open Mike Shit.
And I'd go up there and fuck around whatever.
Boom.
I go to this one.
And uh,
ed,
when you don't,
Edwin San Juan.
Yeah,
I finally go to a real underground Latino comedy show.
You know what I'm talking about?
It's a Wednesday.
There's 300
people,
all gangsters.
And it's weird because like,
that was the last time I hit up people out of comedies,
plum.
I remember being there going a full day,
where are you from?
Me?
I'm here to watch comedy.
And I was like,
oh my bad.
Like right not here,
man.
Yeah.
So I,
I go on stage.
Jeff Garcia is up there doing a your Mama joke battle.
I destroy it.
I'm just like the hat.
Yeah.
I sat back
and then he tells me,
hey homie,
you want like you want to start opening up from me?
And I was like,
what's opening up for you right off the bat?
Yeah.
And boom.
Now I'm like,
I don't do Improv's,
but I'm doing other spots.
And by the way,
did you have like a Rolodex of your Mama joke?
Oh,
I have.
I'm on point.
Really is day.
Your mom is lack of Piñata.
You gotta be blind fold before you hit it.
That's,
yeah.
Is that cool?
For sure.
I feel like a Weirdo saying that to you guys.
No,
no,
no.
That's fine.
There's no filters here.
There's no boundaries.
You can fart into a microphone if you want.
Just let me know.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
This is an award winning the last time I farted into something that was event in
prison.
No.
Yeah,
we're jumping ahead.
Okay,
we're going to go now.
Boom.
I'm doing comedy for like a year and a half.
A Wilmer Valderrama spots me at the laugh factory Latino night cause I'm riffing
on fools in the crowd.
I don't have material yet.
I'm trying to find material so I'm riffing,
you know,
I don't even know set up timing.
None of that shit yet.
I'm new.
They just threw me in this shit cause I'm quick.
Right.
So I do MTV.
Your Mama,
I remember that show and I'm winning so I'm,
I'm in like the last round now I'm deejaying at a strip club now cause I'm doing
comedy at night.
So I DJ at a strip club in the daytime.
It's a fucking Friday,
six o'clock.
I'm off work a half an hour.
I don't know where the fucking gain unit comes in and kicks the doors down at a
fucking strip club and I'm deejaying and I don't even dress like a gangster no
more.
I'm wearing like a Dave Chapelle.
I'm trying to dress like Dave Chappelle.
Remember I used to wear those ones on Chappelle.
So like the joggers shit.
Yeah.
And Ed then like they're like where's George Perez?
And I'm just sitting there going,
what the fuck is going on?
Where you're that startled by it.
Yeah.
Like what?
And then my manager was like,
he's rode here,
this guy.
That's what you want.
So I get locked up
a house quickly.
When you get locked up,
do you know why you're locked up?
Right.
Cause that first year,
well they tell you why right away.
Yeah.
You know what,
like see,
I'm not sure what the story is.
How old are you?
Just so I have context.
We need to have two children at this point.
Yes.
Two Baby Mamas.
You're working your day job and you've,
you're in Showbiz,
you're on a TV show.
So your,
your success.
But we don't even know if it's gonna make it.
Yeah.
This is the,
we're like,
we're shooting a pilot.
It's kind of not the pilot,
but it is,
it's like,
it's weird.
Okay.
So you're on your way.
You're living your life.
You're,
you're going.
Yeah,
exactly.
Wow.
Thanks for reminding me.
No,
cause it's Kinda like fuck.
I do remember like,
yeah,
I remember like I wasn't gang banging or nothing.
How long had it been since you'd,
you'd been gang bang?
It's been like a year and a half.
I mean I'm,
I'm,
I'm still in the streets but I'm not at the parties and stuff like that,
you know?
And uh,
yeah,
it was weird though.
Cause before you,
when you go to the county,
you go to the county first,
know what happened.
They take me in,
they interrogate me.
Ah,
yeah.
They're like,
you're like,
Hey,
you see this guy?
You beat him up.
I beat this guy up at the park playing basketball.
I kicked this fucking ass,
like kicked his ass.
Like I won't see that scar right there.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
I kicked his fucking ass.
This is from playing.
We were playing ball and I'm real good at basketball real good.
And I was clowning this full,
you know,
I could talk shit.
So you're getting scored on and this full swings on me and like misses.
And I remember just like body slamming,
punching all kinds of shit.
Fucked him up.
Fucked him up like so bad that people were like,
just getting your car and get the hell out of here.
So that's what I'm here for.
And I'm just going,
you know how you sit in your head thinking you know everything,
man,
these motherfuckers don't got shit on me.
This shit happen four years ago,
maybe three,
four years ago.
Yeah.
He didn't know who I was and no one at the park was going to say shit cause I
was a bad mother fucker back then.
They were like,
hey homie,
we don't know who did it.
You know,
money talks and bullshit fucking walks.
Somebody fucking came through.
This was the rumor that I heard that some punk ass voice,
a kicker with that I used,
I boned is lady.
You know how fucking guys all he bought my lady,
fuck him.
You should get locked up.
Gives my name up.
The Guy sees me on TV
on Yo Mama,
the guy that I beat up.
So he's on your Momma and the guy's like,
that's the guy that kicks your worst nightmare.
But here's the,
here's the thing,
man,
it's four years ago that you'd beat this guy up.
How could he be sure he can positively id?
Do you know what I mean?
You change in four years.
There's DA,
ah,
Riverside,
his sister's Da.
Yeah.
Riverside and it's not,
it's not in mine,
but you know,
they got connections,
they talk,
you know what I mean?
So you know,
I mean,
imagine you,
you're the judge and you look it up and you're like,
oh shit,
this guy already has to gum possessions,
tagging fucking curfew as a kid.
It was almost in juvenile hall.
And so they're just like,
so you know,
I didn't lawyer up or nothing.
Yeah,
I was just like,
so what's up?
And they were like,
well,
you're going to go to the county and you've got to go to court.
And you know,
my brothers,
my family works,
got money,
but I've never
asked them for nothing.
So I called my brother up a dog.
I need to get belt out.
I'm doing real good in my life right now.
I'm a,
I'm not even done filming an MTV,
Yo Mama,
we're not even done because we were still going to do season three.
This is season one.
So,
and he also must think at first when you call,
like you just did some shit.
But the irony is that you hadn't done some shit.
Yeah,
it was,
it was funny.
I remember when I remember this Chola told me,
hey homie,
you got time for doing time.
Yeah.
And I was like,
fuck.
So now I'm out of court and I'm fighting this shit.
Now I lawyered up,
I'm fighting it and I just filmed the showtime special with Joey d is at this
time as I'm fighting,
this is,
I mean the stress of that of course,
but I'm just not thinking it's,
I have so much other shit going on in my life.
So wait,
your brother did bail you out?
Yeah,
my brother bells me out.
And then you get a lawyer and,
and then isn't this basically a case of a guy being like,
that's the guy.
That's the evidence especially,
right?
Yeah.
And then are you,
is the what?
What does the lawyer tell you is what the Lord is like,
check this out.
This happened at the area you're gang hangs out.
You're known for playing basketball,
this part.
Fuck,
you know,
and it was by my house kind of where I grew up and it's all bad bro.
So it was like,
he's like plea deal.
Like that's as well that this is where I fucked up.
The guy was like,
look man,
I remember one time he was like,
hey,
we're going to,
we're going to give you eight years,
cause I broke his eye socket so it's a great bodily injury at three years.
Fuck,
excuse me.
And I'm just going there like,
can I just do weekends?
I'm so busy right now.
You know,
you talked to other gang members that don't know shit and they're like,
hey homie,
just take it to the box.
At the end of the day they're going to see the evidence as low and they're going
to offer you three years,
take it and do half time.
And I'm like,
let's see what happens.
You know.
So My,
my lawyer is postponing,
postponing,
and finally gets to the point where the judge is like,
look,
three years,
I can't give you half,
but I'll give you 80% and the lawyer doesn't even know I'm a comedian now.
I do charities and shit.
So I fire this lawyer,
I get another lawyer,
I'm going to win.
Nope.
I lost July.
What was it?
It was July 16th,
2009 no,
2006 as I got out and all night.
And I remember I stand in front of the judge and he was just like,
Yo man,
we find you guilty bro.
Is that how he said
it was weird?
I remember his name.
Judge Wapner cause
yeah,
that's the Korean People's Court.
You know what's funny is I never watched fucking people's court.
I told someone else they said the same shit.
And I remember like Fox.
So when they say you're guilty,
you don't get a sentencing,
they don't send you that.
You that you go to a sentencing trial now you don't even know how much your life
is ruined.
I want to let her fucking thing.
I want to understand this.
So for the,
for the judge Walker,
his thing was this a jury trial jury,
you did a full trifold trial.
Fuck.
And it was your defense?
I didn't do,
I wasn't,
I didn't go up there.
But to your defendant,
did your lawyer say like that wasn't him?
Is that what the defense was?
No,
the defense was his.
Look,
George plays basketball a lot there.
George did not do this to this guy.
He might have,
cause I told her,
look,
we gotta be honest dog.
At the end of the day,
the Lord is going to the judges.
How I look at it,
judges look at you and they're like,
if you're a fucking liar,
we're gonna lock you up.
Right.
And that wasn't mine.
That's what I fall.
I'm not going to sit up there.
I can't lie like that.
Yeah,
I didn't do that.
Like I would have laughed.
You know what I mean?
Sure.
But my sense of humor,
sure.
I would've been like,
the defense was George plays there a lot.
He goes there.
He didn't have,
he didn't do it.
Look at him.
He's at now,
he knows I'm a comedian,
knows I'm a good dad,
you know what I mean?
Like dude,
he's not even own child support.
Like what the fuck's going on?
And then all these letters,
I had everyone write letters cause I'm fight when you fight it,
I had a lawyer so I can fight it out now that the judge,
the judge said you're guilty.
They put me in jail.
So now I'm in jail and I can't fight this and I'm waiting for sentencing.
So I'm thinking in my head,
fuck them and it gets seven years.
You know,
you're not even thinking,
oh I'm going to do comedy.
I'm more like fuck my family and my kids and him.
Boom.
Ah,
the judge Wapner came out from people's Court fucker.
He was like,
Mr. Perez,
I'm going to give you three years with half time.
He's like,
you know,
you look like a lot of good people came and spoke for you.
And you know,
it's weird cause I wanted to cry bro.
But there's so many other inmates,
they're like,
if I cry I'm at the answer to this shit.
I'm just like fuck yeah,
you know happiest hell you know,
do it at this time I got my girlfriend pregnant like she's pregnant with my
daughter.
I wasn't there for my daughter.
She was born bro.
Like I'm going through shit on my head.
Right.
Sure.
And then boom.
So that means three years with half time meaning a year and a half year and a
half way to think.
And I have a year and a half.
Yeah.
And then what happens though,
now you now you,
you wait in the county and then there's this thing called the chain.
The chain is when they chain you up,
it puts you on a bus and they drive you to Wasco and they've got a prison up
there in Bakersfield is called Wasco anxiety for you.
Just all the fucked up.
Horrible.
I
caught the chain Christmas Eve.
No they can even fucking let you have Christmas.
Yeah cause I'm locked up by my house.
So my family had to come see me on Christmas and I was like,
but fuck it.
You want to get there?
Cause when you get to prison you're it,
it's different.
The county.
You're in a,
I'm in a jail cell 23 hours a day because I'm a high risk inmate gang.
All that bullshit.
So now when you're in prison,
you get to walk around,
but we're gonna we're going to get to that fascinate.
Fuck.
I need a drink.
Yeah.
Do you want some beer?
You want a beer?
You ever hear of these?
Uh,
yeah.
You know what?
Let me get a beer.
No,
you were here.
These,
uh,
remember those Cholos that were gang banging and in Syria and they're like,
they're like,
they went there just to fight.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Oh me.
That's fine.
Now this is the,
the censored one.
That's no fun.
[inaudible] this is a Charles in Syria.
Yeah,
they're letting me shoot guns and shit,
Bro.
Let's see if they do that anyway.
They always do.
I hit on me.
It's fucking morning.
Who's that?
Dan Amigos,
right?
They're all me.
You represent myself.
Only is squeak Romy from that up.
Tracy.
Again,
fucking wine or from [inaudible] power gang homie still [inaudible]
my boy.
And they're just like,
fools are real now.
Now that I know what they are in prison.
The Persians in their main,
Ian's run with the med skins real.
Oh,
they're sued angels interested.
I know that that's who they align themselves with.
Yeah.
Because that's the,
they don't want to eat and listen to nobody else.
So when you hang out with us,
the Mexicans,
you eat with us and you're a lot of shower with us.
We got to get into all this stuff.
Oh yeah.
All the politics choice.
All right,
so yeah,
man,
you gotta remember this?
I've never been to prison.
Yeah.
So I'm saying is it okay?
I know like obviously you,
you run in with crew and getting into wild shit,
but there is a moment when you're going at prison of like terror,
right?
Oh yeah.
Oh fuck.
Is that happened?
That moment happens once I exited that bus because they strip you down of
everything and when you leave the county,
you don't want to take shit with you that you,
so you leave all your food.
Amen.
Is for you guys.
You know,
good luck fighting your case.
Here's that.
The pencils or papers,
stamps,
all that stuff that's needed.
Yeah.
You just show up to prison with all the letters from your family lyrics from
songs.
Cause you always,
that's how you make music in.
There's people send you the lyrics and you sing them.
Yeah.
And I have all my lyrics,
my letters,
my addresses,
the phone numbers that people I needed to talk to.
And the iPhone is not out yet.
Yeah.
So you gotta remember that it's,
it's all fuck.
And then you get off the bus,
you have no underwear,
no socks.
You just got a ghetto ass jumpsuit with fucking sandals on your fully shackled
like Jangle.
Yeah,
St Jangle.
sure.
Yeah,
you're like that.
But without the shit on like ankles and wrists.
So it's a real like shuffling.
Yeah.
And then get off the bus and you walk into an office like this,
there's a desk,
there's women men,
and they tell you,
hey,
get but fucking naked right now.
So your butt naked hanging out with,
no,
you're not supposed to be next to a black guy,
nick,
to a gay guy next to a transsexual.
Next.
You're not,
you don't,
you don't even know who you are around right now.
So in your head you're going,
fuck,
once these cuffs comes off,
I'm ready.
Boom.
Once the cuff comes off,
all right,
hey,
where are you from?
All right.
They put you in like cells and then there was this white boy that came in is,
I was all fucking bleeding this shit and I thought he got jumped,
but he won the fight of this other fool that came,
that was more fucked up.
Whoa.
And then you look at the signs and they say no warning shots.
So shoot to kill.
Yeah.
Then yeah.
Then you wait and you wait like in,
uh,
it'll,
it'll be like a building like this.
They're like sales,
but they hold 300 people and they're already separated.
You blacks,
whites.
Well,
they're asking you once you go in,
hey man,
who are you going to run with it as?
It's not even,
it's like it's already established.
You know,
like when you look,
if,
if I go to prison,
they look at all my tattoos.
They're like,
what's up homie?
Hey,
your people are over there though.
At your car right there.
Orange County a,
that's your car.
Your car is over there.
So,
whew.
Shit.
Wait,
can we back it up when,
go ahead.
So backing up a second,
I know you,
so you'd had a prior gun possession this,
but going a lot of times I be,
I've heard people say that have been locked up that jail,
like county jails in some places are like way worse then depending on the prison
that they would end up,
it was no fuck no was jail.
But when you got to
jails,
just the guards because you're dealing with sheriffs,
you're dealing with people that you're not going to see for a while.
And sheriffs are way different than the correction officers could correction
officers leave with you in the prison.
It's like you live together,
so you're plotting off like if you are a,
you look like a seal.
Sorry.
Yeah,
it's all good.
You have that look a like I fucking smash Cholos when I'm bored.
Yeah.
Do you know how many times,
like especially a few years ago before I was ever on anything that um,
I would be somewhere and somebody would be like,
how's it going,
officer?
What?
And they're like,
you know why he's sharp?
He's clean.
Tell like that.
Cause we both try to,
I'll sharpen each other like,
oh,
I'm going to get the other shit.
No Way.
I keep on asking Tom,
let's say he's going to go to prison and they asked him,
where do you belong now he's are not going to ask him shit.
They know what's up.
There's only one white place.
You Go,
well here's the thing.
He said he's got a
Latin last name.
He speaks Spanish.
He's half protein.
Yeah.
So where the fuck does he,
they still send me the white people.
The whites are going to confront you first.
That's right.
They're going to be like,
what's up?
Hey Tom Thompson.
Gura and they're going to be like,
Whoa,
who's,
who's the Mexican blood in your family?
It's not,
I was adopted,
man.
My,
I'm actually Irish,
so,
oh fuck.
They're going to be like adopted on you.
Gotta go over there and that's good.
Yeah.
Dot.
Did homey.
But he can't,
he can't
Blanton's right.
Roll.
He could roll with Latins if he was just to be like,
look,
homey.
I grew up with Latin.
I don't know.
I don't know the way the whites live.
Cause it's the way your culture.
Yeah.
How you live.
Check it out dog.
Like I'm not from a gang,
but I'm going to,
I'm going to roll with you guys if that's cool.
Then from there on though,
that's it.
That's it.
You cannot no longer leave groups.
Yeah,
that's,
that's it.
Yeah.
That is it.
Tom.
You're in Bro.
And Yeah.
Can't wait.
Looking forward to it.
Yeah.
So you're in and they,
and they separate you.
Yeah.
But let's go back though.
The sheriffs are more chill,
let's say.
No,
they're fucking Dick.
But not as bad as a COO.
Yes,
dude.
When I was,
I was in the county.
Yeah.
Tom,
I don't fuck around Bro.
We,
we started a riot.
Yeah.
And we fucking started a riot and it was fucking crazy.
It,
we did a gangster two,
three in the morning.
We fucking woke up and everybody knew everybody.
We got,
we all pass letters on your homing three in the morning and we're going to get
up or we're going to check these fools.
I let them know who runs this place.
Okay.
So we get up at three in the morning.
Motherfuckers had pissed and their cubs don't want it on people.
We were fucking jumping people.
I don't know where the fucking the sheriff's see there's the guards would never
do it.
The sheriff's come on,
they start shooting us in the face with,
um,
the Kelly bag guns
and to them,
if you get here with the,
well you were in the fight.
So I'm all fucking Welt up in shit.
And then now I went to the hole.
Whenever you get into a fight,
you go to solitary confinement.
Yeah.
So I'm in the hole for 21 days and I remember I,
I had to go to court and now you're in a red jumpsuit cause you're a dangerous
inmate.
So now I'm fucking shackled again going to court and uh,
and uh,
and are,
you know,
they're mostly all,
I'm not racist towards white people.
I'm racist towards white cops because of what I've been through.
Sure.
You know,
and uh,
I just remember this young ass for all Roy and I was like,
ah,
you're one of those motherfuckers.
I was in that riot horn.
I was just like,
man,
I'm not allowed to talk to the police.
I didn't answer him.
So I'm fucking cuffed and Shit is mother fucker kicks me and I fucked her fall
forward.
And like I have to get up and defend myself and I remember getting up and I
defend myself and then the other homes are like,
Hey doc,
Nah,
they're going to give you more time dog.
Just chill,
relaxed.
Are we seen it?
You're,
you did yours.
Just chill dog.
And I,
I can't wait to find that fucker.
I hate that I'm successful now
though.
I hate that I'm successful because I want to kick his ass,
but I know the consequences.
I just want to see him and be like,
hey man,
you want to have a talk?
I just want to roast them.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That would be more satisfying.
Yeah.
I feel that way about the jurors.
That put me away.
Like when you looked in their faces
in my head I was like fuck hey.
Like I don't,
I'm not mad at none of them.
I'm not mad at the judge.
They have a job to do.
This is what I learned from prison.
A man,
I fucked somebody up.
I did time.
It's funny over with,
right?
Like I feel free.
And was that guy that you beat up?
Was He in court every day?
Was he like when hey.
Oh yeah,
with the breathing machine.
With a breathing machine.
Yeah.
That's what the fight ended up.
He didn't,
he didn't need one.
He was just,
he was being like,
oh he was trying to get paid.
Cause he seen me,
he was all this shit.
Fuck.
Oh Man,
I want to find that fucker now too.
Damn Tom,
Christina got me.
They're going to play this up.
[inaudible] you guys get their ratings.
Wait.
So,
okay,
so sheriff's obviously it can be dicks but CEO's are a different level.
Well we're not allowed to talk to them,
but they're more respectful.
Who is the correction or we're not allowed to talk to no police,
but the correctional officers are more like,
hey,
good morning.
Hey how you guys doing a,
you guys need to extra towel cause they know.
Respond to that though.
Whenever you talk to a corrections officer or a sheriff,
you have to have another person from your crew with you.
Every race does that.
Why do they do that?
Because you're not snitching cause I got you.
I got you.
Say you were a cop.
I could just walk up to me like,
Yo man,
these fools are gonna stab me.
Yeah,
you don't look at them,
but I saw this going down.
I'll talk to you later,
right?
Hale.
No.
So you always have someone else because you're protecting everything.
You ask for permission.
A,
you know what?
My bunk has ants and shit.
I kind of need a spray.
I need to go ask the cop for something.
All right,
go ahead.
Let me go left of boom.
And you go with someone.
Gotcha.
Oh Wow.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's crazy.
Wait till we get to prison.
Let's go.
So now they give you a big old laundry bag,
like a navy style one,
and it has your,
it has,
uh,
your blues.
Your blues is the pride.
You got blue new jeans,
a shirt like this one.
And uh,
your,
uh,
Bob Barker shoes,
they give you the slip ons that are fucking ghetto is fuck you remember the
shoes?
Yeah.
Marker.
He has prison clothes.
Really?
Yeah.
Called the Bob Barker said,
yeah,
they're bad.
They're vintage now.
Really?
Yeah.
Now prison has this old thing called Pia prisons.
Institutional Art.
And they make all the clothes for all the prisons.
Yeah.
It's money,
Bro.
So this is
weird now Tom,
because like
I've noticed my paperwork,
they got me with the killers because of my record and Wasco.
Defour is considered now it's the whole,
but when I was there it was like,
oh fuck.
It gets crazy now.
So now we leave this building and it's dark.
This is day one still.
Yeah.
This is day one and so you know,
you're know you're going into your people's though,
at least that.
No,
I don't even know.
They don't know that.
Yeah.
No,
I don't even know where I'm going.
Like,
like if I was,
if I was an inmate that wasn't crazy,
they would've put me in the dormitory where I would have been around a hundred
people relaxing,
talking to you.
What's up now?
They put me in a two man cell.
I knew it was coming.
You Walk fucking towers,
people on gun watching you.
There's cages in the hallway that are like from that ceiling,
for that bookcase to that camera,
the cages,
and there's people in there because we'll fight those fuckers.
If we walked down that hallway.
Now your enemies,
all my enemies are fucking insight,
but they're in cages and we're walking to our,
you know,
it sucks,
but I used to call him my home and I've a,
I'm going to go home right now.
I'm walking to my home.
Yeah.
And
it's weird.
We show up to a tower and the guy's like,
hey.
He's like,
what do you got?
He goes,
I got two fools from southern California and I got a black guy.
All right,
cool.
I didn't know there were going to house us together.
So all the blacks are on the bottom and all the Mexicans are on top
and
boom,
I walk in,
they're all talking shit,
what the fuck were you full put to us and all that.
And I just,
I've always known you don't say Shit,
you just do it.
Yeah.
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm biting my tongue and I see a home upstairs.
Good job mommy.
Because you recognize dude.
No,
no,
no.
He,
he could tell I'm one of him cause he's just like,
like I already get the signs like,
you know,
we talked to each other in sign language.
I know how to do sign language as far as telling you just,
yeah,
he's just letting me know like,
I see you keep it all right.
Hey,
you're,
you're going to come up.
And he's just like,
then boom.
Then the gargoyles so boom,
I go up there.
Then once you go into your jail cell,
it's mandatory that you show your paperwork to show what you're locked up for.
Because if that should says pedophile rapist niche,
you're done.
That's it.
So boom,
checks it out.
Oh,
all right,
hold on my homeboy.
Oh.
Oh you and like you got homies from your area here.
Like it's all right.
Cool.
What do you,
what do you,
hey,
that's your bunk.
I get my cleaning spray cleaned my bunk.
Woopty Woo.
Fucking put my clothes.
I'll get my pictures.
You know,
and it's kind of weird cause you know,
I lost my whole comedy
personality for sure.
That was not asked you that.
Yeah.
Now I'm just like,
well saw Paul me a shotgun off from Orange Don.
All right,
cool.
Boom eight.
That's my bunk.
I ain't saying I got kids.
I ain't saying I do comedy.
I ain't saying none of that shit.
I'm a fucking gangster homie.
You know what I mean?
And I didn't know this,
but the cell that I'm going in,
the guy that was just their fucking fought the guards
and
in prison there's four yard,
there's two yards.
Okay.
There's one,
there's like,
we call it the one side to Tucson in the three side and the four side.
That's where the piece of shits are.
That rape as pedophile snitch is a transsexual.
It actually put the gaze yet you have to because if you put,
they put the transsexuals and the gaze with the pedophiles and the rapist.
Yes.
It's protective.
It's a special needs yard.
I see.
So they won't get fuck cause if they get in with you guys,
that's a wrap and you ever see that happen?
Yes.
Yeah.
See what happens is is you leave main line and you go to protective custody yard
and
you're like,
fuck this.
I don't want to be here no more.
Maybe they'll forget.
It's been 10 years.
I want to go back over there where there's life.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Is protective custody is horrible.
Yeah.
You're just there.
You don't know if you're selling is a rapist,
child molester and none of that.
You don't know who you're living with.
And he's a snitch.
He's a piece of shit.
That's all we'd look at it and yeah but fuck all that.
I didn't want to think about that.
So I fucking go to sleep for like an hour and they rate us that my first time in
prison.
Yeah.
And Yeah.
All right,
go ahead.
What's next?
They find,
they find that they rated all the Mexicans cause we were at a war with the
blacks and that only existed on this yard when you go to another yard,
the blacks and the mets,
cause we weren't fighting.
It's weird like other,
it's like communities,
this community.
He's like Nah,
fuck that shit.
They're like Ha.
So it's weird cause we're,
we're at war with blacks and a black came from another side of the prison and
we,
we weren't at war with him.
Oh it was fine.
Yeah.
I remember telling for a doc because in prison,
like the guards play this game where they do unlock,
sold the open a door for people that got to go somewhere and they'll open
another door and if they open enemy doors,
you got to fucking fight.
And they're doing that on purpose.
Yeah,
they're bored.
Bored.
That's fucked up.
Now you mentioned looking fresh.
You're like looking tight,
right?
What,
what's that all about your,
you started to say that and I was like,
let's wait until later.
You went to like out,
uh,
there's,
there's a term that we made up called Bonner rule a home and you want to look
bond a room fucking crease down.
Like you want to show every other race were cleaner than you would dress nicer
than you were.
Tighter than you cab and Cholos always have like that clean hands.
Well that's what we are.
We're like,
hey homie,
like I'm not a piece of shit.
Look at you all dirty.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And that's just how it is.
It's weird.
I still iron to this day.
I don't even go to the cleaners.
Yeah.
You iron your shirt hair,
my suit.
Anything.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's weird.
And yeah man,
it's pride a day or let's say,
um,
so you get your raid,
it's like day two.
Is it slowly?
Are you as somebody like vouching like this who you are?
You want me to make friends?
Well,
it's,
it's the biggest camaderie ever.
Like,
like once I got there,
there was a letter that was sent a weeder.
Hey,
this is the food that's here.
Boom.
And people are like,
excuse me?
People are like,
oh,
I know people from his gang.
Oh,
this feels from a solid neighborhood.
Know what I mean?
Cause we're,
we've been in the game for a long time where I'm at and I kind of know people
and uh,
this is the weird fucking part.
They five,
I did showtime.
I don't fucking know if it came out right.
We have TV in the day room.
No,
they don't fucking have show time.
Do they have a commercial?
Oh fuck I asshole comedy slam because bakes and I'm just going on my head.
What the fuck?
Yeah,
you're like George Perez.
Yeah.
Oh,
but now no one knows me in George Perez.
I'm shotgun.
Shotgun.
Yeah.
I haven't heard my name,
George since I was in the county.
So this commercial airs is,
everybody started going like,
no,
no.
In my head I'm a little heartbroken.
Like,
oh fuck,
all right.
Whatever.
You know.
All right,
fuck it.
It is what it is.
You're in reception for four months.
The first prison I went to was a,
I meet a counselor.
They evaluate me.
They see how I am as a person.
What they asked you like,
what did you do before this?
And I had to put comedian construction worker,
you know,
and they were like,
all right.
So that's the job they're going to give you.
Uh,
yeah.
And you have to have a job to be programming.
And if you have a job now you're allowed to go to yard.
You're allowed to go do get store,
buy stuff and shit like that.
And a,
I'm not going to lie,
Tom and Christina,
I was having the best time of my fucking life.
What,
why?
What about it is good?
Because it's just like I was,
no,
there was no stress of getting up.
There was no stress of bills.
It was just like a dog.
How are we going to survive?
How are we going to eat?
And I was with a solid group of people.
We all like,
we all looked out for each other.
Guys had each other's back.
And uh,
this is a crazy shit is uh,
a white,
a white boy.
Cholo that's half white,
half met the guy that was my celly,
he,
he wa he got took out.
He was a medicated,
he was fucking Weirdo.
Fucking Weirdo.
I remember he tried to scare me one time.
He was like,
Hey homie,
at night I fucking see demons.
And I said,
and I was like,
turn the fucking light on it.
He didn't know what to do.
He was like,
Oh fuck,
I don't match on the line on home.
We're not going to get in trouble if you turn the light on.
He was just like,
oh,
all right,
whatever.
So I honestly think to this day that he told,
cause I was in there working out like fucking,
I was in their work.
You have to work out.
It's mandatory for my people.
You have to get up in the morning when we wake up.
Like say we're in prison right now.
Yeah I'd wake up and,
but I expand saw him that theater.
This is sharp goon from orange St.
So rules good morning.
Wendell's Diaz you'd have to say it.
Nick's really like a roll.
Call it the white people say instead of good morning you say would morning cause
they call.
You would yeah.
Good morning.
This is Tom and then,
but see I'm not allowed to go eat yet cause I'm with high killer inmates.
They just open your door and they throw the food in the tray and then you got
like four minutes to eat it.
I didn't get the train or some bad mother fuckers in your off dude lip old Tom.
Tom.
I'm in Bakersfield and uh,
there's a,
I've never ever been scared of a crip.
That was the biggest fucking crimp I've ever seen this full look like.
He made Busta rhymes look little and he was like Busta rhymes who swore was
fuck,
he was in there for killing three people.
Stupid ass.
Full shot.
Someone at a club in the hallway like,
like in the club,
this will shot fools in the club.
And he was being a very disrespectful dude.
We,
I guess other Mexicans fucking stabbed them before this.
Okay.
And so he decided to piss on one of our doors because when they let you out,
they,
they use the shower's upstairs.
So we use the showers downstairs.
Don't ask me why,
but the cops want to see some shit.
Yeah.
So yeah man,
that was the biggest fucking dude I've ever seen ever.
And you had to,
you had to go like,
no,
like whoever,
like whoever had to get 'em got 'em and I give the homeys Hart who did it
because yeah,
they got,
we got,
we didn't get them.
But see the thing is,
is if like,
if you're a threat to us,
we're going to jump you.
Cause when you jump someone,
they'd get you off that yard and you get ships.
What is,
they call it,
but did,
uh,
what did they call you?
Like disrespectfully?
Yeah.
Cool.
Other races?
The blacks or they would call us Mexico's Mexico.
Beaners wetbacks uh,
fucking chump bottles.
I don't know.
It's,
that's,
that's like a word that Mexicans from America made to Mexicans from Mexico.
Come on homie.
I ain't like I ain't in your pants.
Oh
yeah.
She'd have to kind of school the Foreign Mexicans how we do it or,
and then when we go over there,
that's what they call a fucking shot.
And
I go get some boots home.
You're gonna fuck those pants.
Oh yeah.
It's kind of like we slang switch each other and with the
peckerwoods call you guys anything different or no,
not because we're allies.
Oh you were?
Yeah.
Met Mexicans and whites are allies.
Like we live by the same code.
You got what you mean?
And the Persians and the Armenians.
That's why I want to go back to,
so you said to the Persians in the Armenians also rolling.
Still Gang Banging.
Paul.
Can I tell you what happened to those guys?
Yeah.
Was they got locked up in California,
joined us.
I wouldn't say us because they joined the Mexicans.
And when you get out,
I invest the porch.
You cause you'd alone longer have rights if you're from a different country like
that.
Take you to Russia,
Africa.
They don't fuck around.
Get out of here.
They say shot bows.
Fools to the Middle East.
Oh gotcha.
They were fucking like,
we'll swap that.
Yeah,
I seen that video.
I don't know who they are.
Those holes are with it.
They're the real deal.
They look like they're the real deal.
The real deal.
Motherfuckers will blast on site.
Yeah.
I mean they,
I think they put on a little demo in this video.
Yeah.
That is pretty wild.
Walk me through an average day at prison.
So you wake up,
I'm not even in prison yet.
This is reception prison.
This is a four month period.
This is a four month.
So now I wait am my Wasco?
Yeah.
WASCO.
Oh.
And now I see a counselor and they're like,
all right.
And,
uh,
my girlfriend at the time was real smart and she goes,
hey,
if I write them a hardship,
they'll send you to a prison to closer to us so we can visit you.
So,
you know,
I was with the smart chick,
so boom,
she does as shit and they send me to Norco.
Crc.
How's that?
Uh,
it's not a crazy prison,
but it is,
it's more of a druggie prison.
It's an old navy barracks in more culture.
I hear it's in Riverside,
norcal off the 15.
And uh,
it was pretty fucking scary,
Bro,
because,
uh,
I've never been around other,
it's a level two yard.
When you're in prison,
there's a level one yard.
That's where we chunk Tommy Chong.
When he got locked up,
he was at a level one yard.
It's a,
everyone's going to do two years.
One year you're going home.
It's relaxed level two yards is where I'm at.
It's like,
you know what,
it's chill but shingles down,
right?
You got people that are coming in from a level three yard just to have fun.
They're gonna fuck around and go right back.
Right.
So then level four yard is where I was at originally.
Like it's just after nine o'clock.
If you say a word,
you're going to get beat up in the morning.
Rules,
killers,
gangsters in every,
everywhere.
So,
but compared to where you were at Wasco,
this is definitely a better situation.
Right.
It is a way better situation.
I liked Wasco though,
because I got this fog dude.
But he would tell you that.
Oh Man,
I forgot about that.
WASCO.
I seen my friends from elementary.
No,
and they were pissed.
Why Ain't home yet that you're going to be a comedian in Mickey it?
I go,
oh,
that's got to hurt that though when you,
I mean it didn't hurt,
but it did and it,
it's something that stays with me now.
But now you're doing it though.
Yeah.
I remember this one gangster.
My homeboy big sleeps from basset out there.
Shout out to you.
My boy gave me a lot of knowledge.
He grabs me and equals a homie.
Uh,
my son came in home visiting and he seen you and he goes,
that staff full dog.
He used to do comedy at Casa Latina.
That's that guy.
He's real,
he's with the business.
He's,
he's funny.
And the dad was like,
I see you here and I want you to go show the world what gangsters are that we're
still funny that we could fuck around,
like don't ever come back here.
And I was like,
wow,
that's some real shit right there.
Odi.
Yeah.
All right.
Well,
sorry for the sentimental.
No,
I know.
That's great man.
Yeah.
I never get to talk like this to people.
It's fucking word.
I love this.
Do you know that,
by the way,
this is like an aside
the story before,
but I got to tell you,
I think,
I don't know if I've told you last time I saw you that,
so I used to work for this.
Uh,
I don't want to say this family.
Okay.
In 10 legitimate business and the,
the mother's Mexican father's white guy and the kids look,
they look more Latino.
All right.
They look like their mom.
So the kid,
these are clean cut.
Like they,
you know,
go to school and they,
they,
they're not bad kids,
but the kid loves tattoo,
the boy,
he starts getting tattoos all over arms,
legs in like certain styles that like to the untrained eye you'd be like,
oh those gang tattoos.
And He kinda liked that.
You know,
he kind of liked,
they look like bad ass tattoos.
Like,
uh,
like,
a lot of teenage boys would write like this looks bad ass.
So,
and then you know,
people are like,
what is that?
And he would make up,
oh it's this and that just kind of fucking around.
He gets pulled over for a DUI or you know,
drunk driving,
they take them downtown to twin towers and they throw him in.
Like they just look at him.
Yeah.
And they just throw them in there like you are whatever.
So you know,
you're going in here.
So he's in what used to be the gym,
which is now all bumped up cause it's overpopulated.
Yeah.
Night one.
So he's in this thing,
and by the way,
you know,
other bad ass fools are like,
who are you?
And he's kind of bullshitting to like,
no,
know this is going.
I want to hear,
this is so,
so,
so night.
One of fucking inmate punches a female guard in the face and like a riot and
suse and he didn't jump down.
He's like,
he goes,
it's so chaotic and so crazy that he's walking me through day by day.
He's like,
dude,
I realized on day six,
first of all,
he's in for Dui and it's supposed to be in a drunk tank and just let out,
shout out.
He said,
I go,
so why?
I don't understand why you're not just to,
he goes,
every time I would call to a guard be like,
like,
here's my situation.
This is,
you know,
this is not right,
or whatever.
He's like,
Garth.
He would be like,
shut the fuck up and like he wouldn't even be able to get out because of,
yeah,
they're like whatever he's trying to and they all think he's bullshit.
No one's listening to anything.
He says.
He goes,
it's day six and I haven't taken a shit yet.
I was like,
what?
He goes,
well,
I would go to the bathroom and I would sit down and if I was sitting on the
toilet,
like let's say 20 seconds later,
just two dudes walk in in,
I'd be so scared that something's about to happen.
I just pulled my pants up and my body would just shut it down.
It just kept shutting down.
Anyways,
he lasts,
he,
he lasts out there,
you know,
I don't know,
like another fucking five,
six days.
And then they move them to the,
uh,
the valley.
They call it the Hilton,
like jokingly,
they call it the Hilton because it's so much better than the towers.
And then he's there for,
and then he's like,
he goes,
that one's pretty cool.
I'm like,
you have think you haven't done anything bad?
Like you're just,
you got a Dui.
He's like,
yeah,
we're playing cards,
having fun.
It's not because he did something else.
It's not catching.
He,
I don't know.
Well,
he ends up doing,
he gets out,
uh,
two weeks late as two weeks for getting pulled over for a Dui.
He must have been speeding or something.
I think so.
Yeah.
And then they,
um,
he said they just,
you know,
he finally gets out.
But that dude,
part of the reason was that he wa he basically tried to look like he was homing.
Bang.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah.
Uh,
my son has my son's 22.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
And he's tatted up and I'm,
the first one broke my heart,
but I was like,
fuck,
what am I,
he got the same thing.
Me All my family got our last names on her stomach,
you know,
it's a Mexican thing and he got,
and his cousin did it.
I was like,
fuck.
And A,
I remember my fucking son,
stupid ass.
Those the Ohio and gets locked up in Ohio.
No,
for like Dui kind of fighting.
Fighting.
Yeah,
he's,
yeah.
And I remember he was just like,
Dad,
nobody would even talk to me because of the tattoos I had.
Oh,
you're so lucky you weren't in California full.
Yeah.
Because a lot of people don't understand
all this shit right here
is stands for something and you're going to get called out for it.
Sure.
Aidan,
who,
who gave you that?
Is that how that works?
Who gave you that?
Yeah,
and I'm just like,
oh,
it was the homie right here from that point.
He blessed me with this.
That's what you say?
Yeah,
the homie right here,
my home,
but rd right here.
[inaudible] blessed me with that.
Oh,
okay.
And uh,
it's,
it's Kinda like,
you know,
like when someone has like a calendar and it has oh seven oh six or five,
those are all the years he did.
Damn.
Yeah.
That is my friend.
He would have been like,
uh,
Scott
at the mall.
He did,
I paid him like $1,000.
He did this.
What's the most common prison tattoo?
Your last name or your city?
Yeah.
Your last name,
your city.
Everyone gets portraits of their mom.
Uh,
yeah and like fuck.
Oh wait,
before I forget,
you said when the,
when you got that sentence that it was three years,
50% and you're like,
oh shit,
I thought I was going to do,
so what happened to that?
That we're going to get there.
Okay.
It's crazy.
Like so much shit happened to that date.
So
you know,
you want to wait for that one?
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
As the one,
I forgot that happens in the later time.
Okay.
No,
no,
we'll wait.
Yeah.
A dude,
it's,
I have nightmares of this shit,
Tom.
Two,
three times a week.
Fuck,
I'm sorry.
I don't mean to give you nightmares or bring it up.
No,
no,
it's,
it's weird cause like,
you know,
uh,
I used to do a lot of fucking coke man.
It,
that's the only drug that I could do and still be responsible.
Weird Shit.
Yeah.
And I've been sober now for like 11,
10 months from coke.
Yeah.
Like all have withdrawals once every two,
three months.
But it's cool because I'm good and like I haven't done it in like a four months
solid and my body's like fucking my brain up.
And then did,
I had this dream that I was in fucking prison again and it was weird.
Like I was in prison with my normal clothes and myself when I was like trying to
throw it away,
I'm gonna get in trouble.
It was all right.
Yeah.
So that,
yeah,
it's funny,
the psychology of like what an experience like that does to you for the rest of
you.
It never leaves you.
It's gotta be a PTSD thing.
My brother said that.
Sure it is.
It is,
but it's not,
it's Kinda like being in the marines but you never get to go to war yet.
But,
but here's the thing,
like bring up my,
so my dad was in the Marine Corps and he was in Vietnam and he was out in the
Bush like in the shit.
Yeah.
And Real Shit.
Real Shit.
People,
you know,
bodies blown up next to him killing people,
people being killed.
I didn't realize for a long time like you know,
someone raising me my whole life to where adults now how like,
cause he was the kind of person who if you're like,
I want to talk about beating him,
he'd be like,
yeah,
sure.
Like some people are like,
I don't want to talk about that.
And so you talk,
you like,
oh you,
it didn't affect you.
It takes a long time to realize,
oh it,
it tremendously affected you.
It just manifested it differently.
Yes,
yes.
You know,
so it definitely like who I know as the,
as my dad is,
it truly isn't who he was before that experience.
Fuck No.
And,
and,
and I'll never know who that guy was.
Something happens like my son tells me the same shit you said about.
Yeah,
he goes dad,
cause my daughter met me when I got out of prison and I was completely fucking
different.
My sons had me before.
Oh right.
So they know who that guy was and I remember my kids telling me,
you remember when you fuck that full up for the parking spot like dog,
it was black Friday.
Fuck yeah,
no it,
it,
it has honestly,
man,
I'm glad I went to prison.
It made me realize what the consequences were if I do this shit again.
So you think about it.
Do you ever think about it?
Like when you get angry about something,
like,
so hey,
oh yeah,
somebody disrespects you are or you know does something and you're like still
work at a strip club in the daytime.
You do?
Yeah.
And get some free passes or anything like that?
Both of you.
It's a little clammy.
Uh,
dude,
where I work,
I have to fucking deal with this shit once a week.
Like I work with us,
druggies,
homeless people,
real pimps,
real fucking pimps,
prostitutes.
And I remember just the other day I was driving and I have to go to this alley
to leave my work and this fool's like,
fuck you.
Bhutto so I stopped the car and I reverse it.
And as I'm reversing,
I'm just thinking about my kids and I was like,
I've got to do,
showed the store three hours.
What am I fucking doing?
That's good.
The fucked up part is I had a seat in the next day.
Same Guy.
Same Guy,
because they're homeless.
They live in that fucking down.
Right,
right.
But this is a 25 year old homeless.
Yeah.
That's just there because he wants to do drugs.
And I remember just going,
you know what man for your head,
go ahead.
Walk by.
I one thing about prison is you'll learn to talk to people.
Cause if you had a problem with me,
you'd walk up to me,
George,
you know,
while you're looking at me weird at times.
And I don't know if it's cause you have a problem with me.
I said something before like so what's up homie?
Do you have a problem or not?
Because I don't want to live in here thinking mean you have a problem.
Right.
So I did that to that guy.
Go,
hey man,
I work right there and you talk shit to me yesterday.
Like did you not know he was mean or like you know him,
he was all,
yeah.
And I was just Kinda,
and then you know,
the old gangster came out of me.
I was like,
yeah,
I knew you were a fucking bitch doc.
Look at you.
You're 25 you're a disgrace.
Homey.
Like if you get locked up all,
you're going to find out what's really up.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Shit.
His pants,
he shit his pants.
He had fucking shotgun.
The DIY gang.
I've heard other girls say what you just said right now.
I said it's fucking funny.
Oh my God.
So,
so,
okay,
so four months in this first place and then the day and so now you're at,
you're going home male prison.
Fuck.
What's that process like?
It's fucking weird cause it's uh,
no,
it's,
it's different.
It's called a bunkie here too.
Yeah.
Now it's r and R,
but now I have a bunkie and I'm in a dormitory with a hundred inmates,
which is better.
Right?
It's better.
But it sucks if it's right at time
coffee,
you guys write it whenever shit needs to go down.
But I mean like is the frequency of that like once a month like no,
no,
it can,
it could go everyday of the week.
It could go like,
oh no,
for five months it,
whatever's going down,
whatever.
You know,
prison is a place where it tells you what you need to do.
Right.
You know,
if someone fucks up and like say you got to go home tomorrow,
Tom Meade,
you're on the yard and a guard walks up to you and you just spits in your
fucking face.
We're all looking at you.
I would be the stupid ass and do something back.
And that instead of saying,
hey,
Doug,
on a mountain dog,
you could fuck me up today.
Motherfuckers don't think like that in there.
Oh Geez.
It's in orange is the new black.
That's the problem.
When they knew they were getting released,
the guards would fuck with the girls to try to get them to act out to increase
their sentences.
It's really food inmates like you don't even want to tell your homies you're
going home.
You don't know.
Someone will try to sabotage you owe me get,
I don't want you to leave dog.
Fuck that shit.
No.
All right,
so now I'm doing my four year term.
It's uh,
it was kind of weird because now I'm with gangsters that are druggies at this
place.
This place is way more like using,
when an alarm goes off,
it is a riot at this place when the alarm goes off.
So almost running with drugs.
Really?
Yeah,
Dude.
It's Day I was at this place called the California hotel,
California.
It was a building that was 11 stories high and we were all on each story and if
you walk up you have to walk up the stairs and fuck shit went down in those
stairs,
really?
Shit went down.
And
you know,
like,
I dunno,
people look at prison like it's a constantly getting hit up.
It's not really like that.
It's like you wake up,
you hang out with your people,
you're hustling.
Like what?
What?
What are you good at?
Do you know how to draw?
Do you know how to Kevin,
Chris just here.
He knows how to fucking draw.
Yeah.
He would have dry heat.
We were talking about what he would've done in prison.
He said I would draw pictures of like naked chicks straight up or,
yeah.
Or like some people could draw your mom or your dad.
Oh,
thanks.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
Well you could tell jokes,
so yeah.
What did they have?
I like your talent.
Like I was ready for this.
One of the fucking guards.
Hey homie.
Okay.
I'm by Ontario Improv.
Ah,
was a dog.
You're that full George Perez,
Huh?
Oh fuck.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
He goes,
yeah,
who am I used to watch you do comedy at down to the cards,
one of the guards.
Uh,
and since I'm in a,
Oh fuck.
So I'm doing halftime.
Right.
So they put me in the program called Sap Sus Substance Abuse Program.
And in this program I'm with all these fucking lame ass druggies and shit.
Yeah.
And it's for halftime.
So,
uh,
my counselor sees me and she's like,
you know what?
There's a mistake.
Okay.
You have a violent crime.
You can't do halftime.
Halftime.
No.
Violent crime is 80%.
How far your sentence?
Yeah.
How much time have you served?
Fast forwarded?
This is two.
This is a a year and a half.
So you're like,
I'm about to get a out to get out of here.
Yeah.
Dammit.
That's gotta be the most crushing thing to hear.
And I've had a lot of other questions.
Shit.
I mean,
when you're like,
I'm about to get out of here.
And they're like,
oh no.
Just like nonchalant,
like a,
I don't give your stuff away.
You're going to do?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Ah,
oh fuck.
That was wild.
Wait,
but what was your job?
My job was wild.
My first job was a yo,
I was on the yard crew.
Yard crew is,
uh,
I check out equipment to everybody that's in prison.
What kind of equipment?
Like a basketball,
uh,
sandbags to work out.
Cause we,
you would put sand in like a,
you see this pant leg?
Yeah.
You'd cut it.
So the bottom put sand in and then put a hole here and those are your wife's
curls.
Wow.
And uh,
because you can't have the weights.
Oh Hell No.
When the weights were in,
people were getting killed,
like written right and left.
I imagine working now and then someone just drops a 45 on your head choirs.
Yeah,
of course.
That's fine.
Go ahead.
Go ahead
horse.
Oh,
you're my hero now they go have dinner after that.
Right?
There's like bap killed.
That dude do to do.
Oh yeah,
it's private.
It's like a fucking celebration.
Yeah.
That's a party I'd go to.
So I'm in the substance abuse program and the war didn't calls me
my uncle's,
hey man,
I got Sacramento coming down here and I to show them rehabilitated inmates.
And if you,
it's weird,
I dress better in prison than I did.
Now wait,
this is the warden telling us award and comes to the program and he goes,
I heard you're a comedian.
I said,
yeah,
I am sure.
You know I'm trying to get the fuck out for sure.
And goes,
well La,
you want to put on a show?
I don't know.
I go home.
Am I a lot of customer calls?
No,
no,
no racism.
No cousin.
All right,
cool.
It's weird man.
I ever been in front of a mic.
Probably a year and a half.
Yeah,
like,
like I'm not worried about being funny,
Tom.
Yeah.
I'm worried about fuck,
am I going to say something that's going to give me stabbed and migrants,
right.
Sorry,
you're,
you're running it through your head the whole time.
Yeah.
And,
and this is the fucked up part is like fuck full.
If you show them how funny you are now,
everyone's going to want to fuck you.
Oh,
that happened to me now.
And uh,
fuck it though.
You know how those demons are.
I'm going to fucking kill this bitch.
I murder dude murdered because they haven't seen that.
They haven't seen copy.
Of course.
Gangsters,
druggies.
And Yeah,
dude,
I started this song,
Rogan man.
It was cool.
He was just like,
hey man,
you can take the rest of that Kentucky fried chicken and that two liter Dr
Pepper back to your pad.
And I remember going back to my gel,
saw what that shit everybody like walked off
and I gave it to all.
I gave it to everybody we ate.
So do they,
do you tell them why at the time or do you still hold onto that?
No,
I told him.
You told him you gotta remember I'm,
I'm in the hotel.
There's three other,
there's three other yards to this prison.
I'm in the drug program.
Right.
So now that that we find out I'm not supposed to be in this program,
they send me to the three side God and I'm loving it.
I'm cool.
I mean,
dude,
I can,
I'm loving this shit.
I don't want to be with drug is I want to be with gang members.
As weird as that sounds,
I actually think it makes sense.
Yeah.
No,
they're like,
they're on fucking pills meds as the fucking dude.
I remember snorting Seroquel,
Seroquel.
It's a even heard of that.
It's a,
I guess suicide thoughts or like if you hear people speaking in your head,
you take this drug,
whoa dude.
Get your schizophrenia.
Yes.
Yeah.
And I remember we were sniffing it because we're bored as far course African
snippet.
Yeah.
For Real.
So now,
ah,
how many people come to the er or invited to at all whole program?
Was there,
the whole program like Sacramento was there.
Like the people that like evaluate,
oh,
you know,
this prison is doing a great job.
And they were like,
oh my God.
He came in and gangster,
that was a comedian.
You guys brown back to being a comedian.
Hilarious.
And I took it.
I ain't give a fuck.
Of course,
you know,
you know I asked,
I asked for brand new pants,
I go home and can I get new pants,
a new shirt?
I want to look fresh in here.
And they're like,
yeah,
hell yeah.
Yeah Dude,
I made the warden look fucking bomb.
Yeah.
Now I'm over here.
I'm with real gang members and some of these fools then over from the streets.
And that looks so for heard you were here.
Oh Shit.
Even my home for from my gang is in there.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Like I remember going to yard and that was the first time I heard my name.
I heard,
Hey Georgie and I turned around,
what the fuck?
Oh Shit.
What's up Evans?
And the guards are all Mexican.
It was cool.
All the guards are med skin and they were like,
hey homie,
we know who you are and uh,
would you do a show for us for the guards?
Yeah.
And I'm like,
what do you mean do I go,
why can't,
you know what I mean?
And I was just like,
and I,
you know,
cause you have to ask for permission.
So I bought the guy with me and he goes a dog.
Hey Doug,
why don't you ask these fools if you can just do all the dorms.
That way everybody,
all the inmates get to see you do comment
on a a,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not going to go up there fucking biting the bullet.
I formed a crew.
I got me a feature.
Yeah,
you're going to open the show man.
I go look doc,
check this out.
And,
and the fee to get in my show was one item.
So fools or put like a cup of noodle rice beans.
That was my hustle dude.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was my,
I did nine shows in prison.
Nine fucking no mine.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
How so you trained a couple of guys to like kick things off.
Like,
like you know when you meet so many you're like,
dude,
you're 40 you just don't know cadence.
You don't know the setup tag.
You don't know none of that.
So I helped them with their shit.
Shut up.
Yeah.
This waffle with fucking anything was Rico.
He's a fucking big old tweaker.
He got locked up because,
uh,
you know,
I guess there's like a base around here,
Los Alamitos base or okay.
And he would,
he would jump into like the water and steel,
like muscle and sell it.
Like he was a Druggie,
so he would still,
Koi fish is from Manchester.
He will smooth,
those things are expensive.
Quite are like $1,000,
you know,
you know when you need a smart drug.
He was definitely,
he was fucked.
And he had this one joke that kill me.
He a fuck the teeth is like,
Yay.
I used to cut girls on the party line and I would tell them I'm chisel.
It just killed me.
He did it better.
But uh,
yeah,
man,
I did a,
I got,
would you,
how would you open like your prison show?
You what I mean?
Like when you got up there though,
this full brought me up the smoothest.
He was like,
you could see them on showtime.
You could see him on the yard now.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I would just fucking,
I would come out,
I mean it was,
look,
Mexican people don't get disrespected by this.
All right.
But it's fucking easy to do a Mexican show because there's not that many Mexican
comedians.
Right.
You know what I'm saying by that.
So I would just go up there and it's boom.
So last time I know,
I know what to do and then I'd give them the,
the,
the smart part of that.
Yeah.
But uh,
how long would you do a set for?
40 30.
Hadn't done it for a minute,
but you know,
I was writing.
Oh,
so you were still thinking?
Yeah,
I was thinking,
but it was dumb shit.
Dumb.
Yeah.
He also had to make it for like the world you're in
the food,
you know,
you're talking shit about like the,
he can't talk to you about the Cos,
right?
No.
Yeah.
But I did it.
It was more like,
yeah,
that's a great question.
Are you talking about like,
Yo is Thursday we're going to shower today?
Mother shower everyday?
I don't know.
Mandatory mandatory two times.
Two Times.
Yeah.
I would get up at five in the morning and then shower and then I was uh,
I was a butcher,
I was a,
I was,
here's my second job.
I'm the,
I'm the lead man and the butcher shop and uh,
you get that.
It was cool man.
Christina,
they gave me a blue jumpsuit or like a mechanics.
I didn't feel like an inmate.
I had fire man boots,
thermal under beanie,
black gloves,
big ass Dickies jacket.
And you have to wash your clothes so there's no washer.
So after you work,
you wash your clothes in the shower with soap and take it off.
You can't get up every day.
You had to wash your clothes by hand after work.
No Shit.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Walk me through your day.
So it's 5:36 AM five 30.
It's at four 30 in the guard will walk by and be like,
Perez,
wake up.
You've got to go to work.
I know you,
I know your routine.
Go ahead.
Jump in the shower cause you're not allowed to be in the showers at those times
to shower alone.
Well,
it can wait.
Now I'm in a dormitory.
So there were showers and restrooms.
You could use a restroom,
but the showers and a lot of turn on unless it's for a worker.
Okay.
Because people will go in there and shit happens.
What kind of Shit?
Like fucking stabbings,
druggie drugs and the cops,
the cops are like bay overpaid babysitters.
They're more like,
look,
you're not gonna get in trouble if you're fucking in your bunk,
so stay in your bunk.
That's all they want.
You know?
And uh,
so I get up,
boom.
My homeboy peewee,
he worked at me,
saw pee wee.
I know you're not listening,
but what's up?
He was,
he was the guy that got me the job,
actually saw that.
Love this guy.
We still talk to this day.
So he got out and uh,
we would go to work.
So now the card leave,
you leave your building,
you're walking down the hallway and you have an identification card.
And on the back of it,
it tells the other guards your duties.
He's a lot of B at this time.
He's allowed to go to this cause I had to leave my yard to go to another yard to
go to the kitchen.
And it's everyone that works early is going,
but when you're in the butcher shop,
I had to cut enough meat for every inmate in all the prisons.
So you know,
I know my math,
I'm smart,
but I graduated high school and went to junior college for one year.
You know what I mean?
I'm one one semester.
I didn't say one year,
one semester or one quarter,
whatever the shit me maybe a couple months.
And I was the shit at that.
Like when we would steal,
I wouldn't steal.
I would put it like,
look,
we sent this there,
but it never got there.
We took it.
So yeah.
So okay,
sorry,
I'm jumping ahead a jump.
Crazy.
So now you have to go through a checkpoint.
The guard search,
you go into the kitchen and then you meet up with all your coworkers and that's
the best shit.
You know why I'm surrounded by eggs all.
I wouldn't make bomb Brett.
We would have French toast,
scrambled eggs.
How often?
Every morning,
every morning I'm in charge of the food.
That's the shit.
And the guards,
the guards,
the guards were like,
this fucker's doing comedy for the whole reason
you're privileged side.
No,
no,
no.
That was along the same lines is like,
so the guards were cool with you having this great feast every morning?
No,
they didn't know because they didn't know the guards in and charge,
you know more.
There's this thing called free staff is they hire people that are in charge of
like,
these people have worked at juveniles and now they want to make more money so
they go get a job at a prison.
Like you got a dentist in a prison,
that's free staff.
You have uh,
you know,
what's that shit called?
Psychiatrists.
Counselors.
Those are all free staff people that are making like,
do you want to be a cook for 18 bucks or be a $45 an hour cook in prison.
Oh Wow.
Jesus.
Because there's a risk.
I might stab you.
Right.
All right.
That is a job.
Are there any female employees?
Oh yeah.
Ladies that look like me.
Haley.
And we start at you.
Of course.
So what's up with sex?
Aw.
Do you miss being around,
you know,
women's so much or does it part of your mind just adapt to the,
I'm glad I fuck,
I'm never been a pervert to that point of view of,
but like there's a price to pay for that.
Like if you get,
if you get caught jacking off,
it's kind of like disrespectful to somebody.
So I wasn't even more like really I'm marijuana time.
I jacked off once taking a shit cause I was just like fuck,
I'm taking it.
I remember free staff,
free staff was like,
cool,
go use that restroom.
You have to hurt me.
Cut,
meet her restroom.
I'll just fuck tissue.
And it came back,
I was out,
I had a bomb one.
Like I don't know,
like I would smell women and that would fuck me up.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The smell of perfume or where do you jerk off on the toilet?
Do you do know?
Sitting down.
So you just look like you're shitting.
That's your regular spot though.
And that's not,
I mean,
every like,
okay,
so like say this is a bunk.
All right.
Yeah.
Right here.
You have a curtain right here,
Kurt.
Okay.
Can I tap your bunkie on top a homie.
Hey,
here's a little,
here's a little cinnamon roll for you dog.
Let me give mine.
Really?
Yeah.
And that was,
that was that cue?
Like to either get out or just chill?
No,
it was just like,
Yo,
dog.
I'm going to bust a nut.
Keep pointing for me.
Okay.
Key point meaning,
watch out.
Point is like,
so what do they expect?
You guys who would never jerk off.
Yeah,
but it's for other inmates,
for other races.
Like you don't want to start a war with the whites because you're looking at
this white dude jacking off.
Right?
Or The black guy.
You know what I mean?
You don't want to start a war.
So I'll say eight dog,
cover yourself.
Go handle it.
It's weird.
Plus you don't want to be caught by your enemy jacking off.
They keep pointing for me,
dog.
Something happens,
let me know.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh Wow.
So you would target me.
So let's say I'm working.
Oh hell yeah.
That's hard.
What am I,
what's my job at the prison?
Let's just,
let's just say you're a dentist and you have to have inmates work for you now.
Oh fuck.
Because you're x-rays.
We got to go do your paperwork.
So,
you know,
it starts off.
Good morning.
Hi.
And then you're bored.
You're there 12 hours a day.
I'm writing you love letters.
Every fucking I'm not [inaudible] no,
no,
no.
I understand.
Saying like,
are you giving them hell yeah.
Even working here
and you're like,
oh my God,
look,
you gotta remember I'm fucking ripped.
I don't eat sugar.
I don't need salt.
I work out every day.
The meat.
You're got the prime meat eating your breakfast.
Your ass fucking fucking gorilla.
Yeah,
I was ripped when I got him.
I wish I had that body.
Ah,
AH,
prison body.
So wait.
And then if you,
if you connect with like the female,
well that's the whole hustle.
Hustle.
So I'm going to convince you,
you know what?
Homegrown.
Yeah,
I love you man.
And when I get Outta here and we're going to get married,
but
right now there's no cigarettes here and they really don't trip on you.
So a,
if you can sure.
Just bring like,
bring like
are you down at bringing buglers pack?
What?
Do you have a mailing address?
I'm going to show you,
I'm going to show you how strong I am.
Christina.
Boom,
money order goes out.
Dan.
Thousand Bucks at the crib.
She'll bring that shit.
Dude.
That's,
but I mean,
are you also trying to fuck,
I'm sorry.
I mean fuck.
Hey,
this,
this is,
I've never seen it,
but I've heard of it.
I almost,
there was a CEO.
I don't want her to fuck me.
Really?
Yeah.
I know this shit for real.
And uh,
it happens usually it happens everywhere,
but it usually happens on the,
like the higher yards where it's just like you're bored.
You don't have a husband.
Right.
And all this mail and shit ass motherfucker.
Right on your poem.
Yeah.
You never been fuck like that before.
Right?
I'm doing a thousand burpees a day right from Mantech who are all about the lady
knew Morrissey drawing.
Fucking smashing.
Yeah.
No.
Well,
let me ask you this.
You got to start going to prison.
There's a consequence of this because if you get caught,
oh I'm going to prison.
No,
your night losing my license.
At least this mother fucker rate me.
He's,
oh right.
Oh fuck.
Now you're
fuck the guy is.
Yeah.
There was when I was there,
when I,
when I left,
cause I still kept in contact with some of the guys I was locked up with.
They were like,
Hey,
remember that chicken?
I was trying to bone you.
She was born in another inmate and it's it.
It,
it,
it happens with guards too.
Yeah.
It happens with everybody.
Counselors.
It's isolated world too.
You know.
Feel like an opera.
Yeah.
Now I'm going to ask you what about butt sex?
Oh,
I'm not saying you do it.
I'm saying have you heard everybody that the stereotype is that rape is the big
fear.
Every guy I know and that fear of going to prison,
I'm going to get right,
I'm going to get raped,
I'm going to get rid of.
So how true is that?
Ah,
you're only going to get raped if you're a bitch,
you're not going to get rid because it's not allowed.
It's,
it's uh,
it's fucking more frowned upon than anything really.
Gay activity in prison is like,
Yo,
homie,
you're done.
Like they're going to kill you.
Like there was a guy going home,
this happened in another,
another dorm next to mine,
three months.
God,
his Dick Suck on another man,
convinced them to let him suck his dick.
And somebody seen it.
It was three in the morning in the fucking showers.
I remember being on yard this day.
Chelan you know,
uh,
if it's baseball season,
they check our baseball bats.
If it's football season,
the checkoff football,
it's baseball season and that they were having a tournament.
The guys had their bats and balls and they killed this motherfucker,
the one who god is,
but your own race has to handle it.
They killed them.
Killed him.
Fuck.
Yeah.
And I was just like,
it's,
it's not to be played.
That's kind of a myth.
Real.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
well,
I mean that you're going to get out a mix.
It's of like,
remember what I said,
that's what our race is.
Do Gotcha.
Are Racist.
Don't play that shit.
I don't know what those other races are playing.
I'm sorry your us too.
And I'm so excited I get to be in part part of your crew.
We listen.
Let me ask you something about loyalty real quick.
God Sake.
I love you guys.
I have a feeling
no.
How's this going to go?
So no you don't.
I'm going to pitch you a hypothetical scenario.
Can you tell me your opinion on it?
Okay.
All right.
So,
um,
obviously married to this lady here for,
uh,
10 years together.
15 total.
Right.
And in this scenario,
would I tell her is I like my ice coffee a certain way.
Okay.
And a lot of times I go and it's not made to,
my satisfaction is frustrating.
So I've learned to ordered a certain way.
I make certain amount,
you know,
to fix,
to get it the way I like it.
So what I was telling her was like,
what if in this hypothetical scenario,
one day I kept going the same coffee place I always go and I felt like this
person wasn't purposely disrespecting the way I want my coffee.
No,
wait a minute.
You haven't a dad detail.
They were purposely disrespecting you.
Well this is an added detail.
Okay.
They're making it income,
not targeting you.
Yeah.
We're not going to make your coffee.
They were not like fuck your coffee Barista.
My bad.
I didn't mean to make it like go pee.
Okay.
I've told you
fucking times how I like it.
So this time what happens is this person's shift ends and I just happened to be
waiting.
Oh
look at him light up when they walk back to the right.
Correct.
Like a Christmas tree.
I grab my,
pull him into the bushes.
I smashed his head against the pavement.
I stomp on his neck and I break his neck to make sure it's broken.
And then I put them in the trunk of my car and I go home.
She's out.
She's,
you know,
doing check shit,
get her nails done or something.
She comes home and she's like,
what's up?
I go,
I got to tell you something.
All right.
Had a little,
I had an oopsie this morning.
Uh,
I was going to get coffee.
You know that fucking idiot.
He never makes it right.
I killed him.
He's in the trunk now.
Does your loyal spouse of 10 years,
the two small children and the for all right,
we need to figure out how we're going to deal with the situation or here's
scenario number to call the cops
while he's thinking about it.
He's a thoughtful guy.
Well,
I'm only to,
the point is,
is if I'm Christina,
I'm like,
does this full beat mean?
Does he take my money?
Does it let me spend?
No,
he's,
he's good to me.
If he's only been addictive foods that make coffee.
Yeah.
I'm fucking back in my boy up.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Big Girl Voice of reason has spoken.
George,
I hear what you're saying.
Is He a good man mate?
Only.
Only because you're the father of the children.
You're doing it for the kids now,
but like at the end of the day,
you know what Fucker,
you're not drinking coffee no more
rolling Boone this year.
One no more coffee for you.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I didn't think about that.
That's some shit.
You really trip on motherfuckers for coffee like that.
Ship them.
Yeah.
Oh,
then I would trip if you tipped,
you got a trip?
Yeah.
I said well to yeah,
I tip well,
yeah,
I,
I get it from the Strip club and your words if you,
but if they,
if they,
if I tip good and you're taking forever.
I don't like that shit.
It is.
You're good.
I got your back now.
Thanks man.
Yeah.
All right.
Well,
let's say he's never,
he's never exhibited.
And I tell you this,
I go behavior before I tell you what,
what's wild about her in this scenario?
She's so calm.
Well,
no,
she,
she'll fucking wrong.
One of the culture,
the scenario,
she's like,
yeah,
no.
I called the cops and I immediately,
immediately,
why I go wait by George.
She goes,
what if you decided to kill me in the kids?
And I'm like,
why do you know why he wouldn't talk?
Because he told you how do you oh interesting.
Because he confessed to me,
here's my concern.
He's a normal guy.
Otherwise one day because his coffee isn't made right,
he snaps and he kills the guy that leads me to believe there's a screw loose.
He's snorting Saran offenders.
Huh?
Or You could look at it like fuck cause homies crazy.
He's never yelled or hit me.
Right.
I fuck up all the time.
He fucking loves me.
He's tripping on fools that make coffee came on them and I'm over here not doing
shit.
Yeah.
Also like how cool is that?
Your husband's so passionate about something,
get the fuck out of here,
but you know,
real psychos and that's a real cycle move to kill a man cause he didn't make
your coffee.
Right.
That's kind of like a,
I don't know.
I mean I keep telling the guy how many times I gotta tell him straight up.
I mean,
yeah,
like extra ice pitch.
Like put it in there,
but here's the problem.
What if I help them get rid of the body?
You can't.
That's when you just gotta be like,
Yo Homie,
I'll see you at the next city.
That's it.
Wait,
what cm in the next city?
Meaning he gets rid of the body.
I take the kids and we go.
Yeah.
The thing is,
is now the number one priority is kid.
Yeah.
That's what I look,
Tom,
I'm jamming with the kids.
Right?
You clean this shit up.
Yes.
We'll see you with some no coffee.
Get a sprite.
Yeah.
So
here's the deal.
I wouldn't help him bury the buy.
I wouldn't help him get rid of the body can't because now you fuck it up.
Someone needs to be just locked up.
That's what that was my thinking.
Yeah.
Seriously.
With calling the car,
like I'm not a fan of calling the cops.
I'm sorry.
But I did want to be there to raise the kids
because if we both get locked up,
who's going to take care of these kids?
So that's why I was like,
I'm not going to help him cause then I'm going to get put away.
That's what I'm thinking.
I'm never even called the cops for help.
Yeah,
I wouldn't.
You call the cops before on Tom?
Never.
No.
Yeah,
that's fucked up.
Shit.
No,
never date a cop when I got out of prison.
Oh wait.
So how does it get your sentence?
Fuck,
we didn't even cause the photo.
You're in the wrong program.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
Sorry.
I thought something else had happened.
That's terrible.
What's it like
if you've been locked up total of three years?
Yeah.
Be with a woman.
Oh my God.
After three hours.
Really.
Only because like,
so check this out.
Hey man,
how can I say this?
Like I'm shotgun.
Doggy.
Shit happens.
So in prison I,
I made my context outside.
I said,
look,
I don't want nothing.
Everybody getting a hundred bucks I need,
I'm going to throw it out there.
All right,
Russell.
Fucking Peter's buys me a cell phone when I'm in prison
because he goes,
Edwards,
he asks about me.
He's like,
what's happened to George?
And Ed was like,
oh dude,
he's locked up Russell.
I love you brother.
He didn't know he was Miami,
a cell phone,
but he gave him money and Edwin goes,
where do you want to say I want a cell phone,
bro.
I want to talk to my kids.
I want to talk to my wife and I love Russell Peters.
He's awesome.
He's been sweet to us.
That's great guys.
Yeah,
so I know I got sex.
Talk on the phone.
The WHO's who,
are you busting nuts in the first time you get out?
Like who's your,
is it your top?
My girlfriend.
The baby's mom.
You date a cop?
This is the crazy shit is nobody wants to book me no more and I get out of
prison.
What?
I would have booked you first.
I feel like this guy's got some shit to talk about now,
but they're like,
I didn't,
I wasn't at the store.
I wasn't nowhere I,
I was doing the little Latin community and Improv and like Latin shows.
I didn't know that much.
I only be at the store for four or five years now.
I was doing other shit.
So like
I fucking hit up my Texas connects and I,
and you had a member of this?
I'm on parole.
That's right.
It was all about that.
No one's going to,
I can't feed my family.
I've got to,
I got to risk it.
So I go to fucking Macallan Texas are you got to remember like I'm smart and not
saying this to be modest or Hubris.
I'm smart because I'm not going to get locked up.
So I'm fucking dressed like a square,
like fucking skinny jeans,
fucking old p shirt.
Like I looked like a square and there was this cop in the crowd and she was just
like,
I don't know if I wanted to arrest you or fuck you.
And I was like,
what the fuck?
What's going on?
I was nervous.
So,
uh,
I get her number and I'm there for four days and the next day after the show
she's like,
hey man,
you want to meet me?
And I hop on my
delicious.
Yeah.
I don't get offstage til one o'clock in the morning at this point.
You know she's a cop or no?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
But I thought she was like dispatch.
Yeah.
You know,
she doesn't know them up role.
She doesn't know none of that shit.
So,
uh,
she Latina,
he cores.
That's all there is a Macallan.
I don't know.
I fucking show up all gangster it out to the,
I hop and she's in her full uniform and everyone's looking at me like I'm a
snitch.
Thought it was fucking weird because we had our own holiday.
Yeah.
That was crazy though.
We fucked for like,
I did four more shows out there that came back.
Then I dated this other cop.
She was ex,
she was divorced from a cop and stop being a cop.
It was fucking crazy.
That's funny.
It's gotta be like a fantasy fulfillment for these.
Uh,
no,
it's the way I'm telling you.
I'm like a cop to them.
I'm a clean cut fool.
Yeah.
I'm kinda direct.
I have a program I run and that's,
that's just to shut the end.
But I'm different.
I'm not a corn ball like that for I smoke weed.
I drink.
Yeah,
you're fine.
You know,
hang out with,
I hang out with fools that kill motherfuckers.
I fuck up the coffee.
You know what I'm up,
dude.
Yeah.
You guys roleplay,
which she'd be like,
Nah,
she was Chang.
Bang.
She was like beat up by that cop.
It was weird like it was really,
that was the first time I was kind of like,
I want to fuck this full up,
but I really can't because he's a cop.
I guess he would handcuff her.
Like he would get mad at her and handcuffed her and just leave for like what
hours?
Yeah.
Jesus.
She was fucked in the head.
It's not her fault.
It's,
it's,
it's what it was,
but like,
yeah,
he was fucked in the head too.
Fuck man,
that's a car.
I haven't talked about that shit in forever.
A question off topic,
but it's whatever you like.
We asked Danny Brown when he was here,
what his favorite snack was in jail and he would make prison burritos,
which was slim Jims dorito chips chopped up and then you roll them and then you
heat them up and the cheese would kind of melt.
Oh,
and a cheese stick to what was your go to a prison meal.
You're jam man.
That's your friend was poor.
If he think that access to good food.
He was in jail though.
Yeah,
though we dude,
we fucking made is one time we had dogs.
We got all,
everybody pitched in like 45 Dorito bags.
He put a little bit of water and we grinded it out.
It's always,
it always starts with Doritos.
We grinded a mountain.
That's the Masa.
And then we,
I bought all the roast beef,
we played it,
we put it in in a five gallon bucket with the Stinger warmed up,
boiled,
and then we've got all the spices marinated that she's fucking ingenious.
They come up with,
aw dude.
What about like white lightening?
Did you ever make some crazy?
We made provable wait,
layman's.
Too scary because there was people that went blind from Nash.
I know you've seen that on documentaries.
You want to fight somebody?
Yeah.
White Langton is no fucking around.
But we had Bruno and Bruno.
But when you get caught,
we're pruned.
No,
that's three more months they had to yourself not worth it to get fucked up.
Right?
Like how'd you get,
how'd you get the fucking gone on Pronamel shit myself because my stomach has
never had nothing like that.
Go through it.
I remember almost shitting myself.
Really?
Hell,
how do you make a Bruno you okay,
so I'm going to show you the real way to make,
okay.
Say this is a container of nuts.
You get the bottom part,
you cut it out and you poke little holes in it.
Like kinda like how would it,
not holes but like a triangle.
So it has teeth.
Do you know what I'm trying to get at now?
When you use a can opener.
Exactly.
So now you get fruit and use that to grind the fruit and you're grinding this
fruit in a pillowcase.
Alright because you want to strain it all just to be,
that's going to be your alcohol.
So you get all the fruit,
boom,
you squash it,
you get all the juice out of it.
And then you're a,
call it a Stinger as well.
Like the,
the center of it.
all the food you have together after you squeeze it,
you put it back in the five gallon thing and you put sugar in it and then the
sugar burns it like you gotta let it,
we call it burping.
But what would it be?
The curriculum.
Fermentation.
Yeah we call it burping.
And don't forget to Burp it.
So you,
you put like a straw in it for men,
not the window.
Cause we have windows little windows and you let it cook for like four or five
days.
Six if you're a GI cause you're going to get caught with this shit.
Cause they always search us.
They're always on us.
So like say we're in prison,
you would have it one night.
You would have it when I would have everyone who moves in.
Yeah.
We're all fucking helping each other out.
Smart and you put it in a coffee container and sell it for 1520 bucks each dam
or you fucking just drink it and you're done.
But it's not allowed no more because you fight it.
It gives you courage.
I never even thought you had fuck that shit right now.
You know what that felt like we'd though,
do you have access to weed in there?
Everything.
And you trade what?
Commissary or you put money in the guys,
whatever.
Any everything's currency.
Like if you want to a Homie,
I'm going to draw you a pain.
Let me get three landlords.
Let me get,
let me get it.
Let me get a dime piece.
All right.
Yeah,
I used to smoke a lot of lead in there.
Really had access.
But where would you go to actually light up dude,
I fuck him.
I got a lighter and okay,
so every locker has a lock.
You know?
Remember the old masters,
is that what it's called?
You know the back has a key.
Put the weed right there.
You light it and then we're like,
the thing goes in,
you suck this
part or you can just get a bible cut a page rolling Bible pages.
Apple.
Paris.
Yeah.
Now what are you making knives out of?
Oh Shit.
Everything brush.
That's too easy.
It over snap.
Really not right.
My favorite knife was a
old speed stick and then uh,
I would uh,
your bunk is solid rock cause it's all concrete.
Yeah.
And then when it gets real hot,
it may take me five hours to make it.
I would just write roll,
roll,
roll at the speed.
Stick the deodorant or the container?
The container.
I would cut it.
Yeah.
Just roll it to get hot.
It would get hot.
Finally would just be this fucking long sharp one hit or quit.
Even the guy from Starbucks is coming back
hoes.
Ain't no fucking joke.
Really?
Yeah.
That's smart.
So you guys are so creative and inventive.
You're going to be,
it's,
it's what we are as humans.
It's survival.
It's like Tom,
you would make it in their dog.
Yeah,
you would.
You would make it,
you would fucking low carb.
Come back with like big ass portrait of Christina right here.
I'm always over here.
Your seeds on you and shit all around the shop.
What's up for real?
You will adapt.
Don't drink coffee no more.
Yeah,
you adapt.
It's fucking fascinating though,
right?
Yeah.
It was kind of like the,
that's the war parallel.
The parallel is that you adapt to uh,
uh,
a situation that's basically not normal.
Right?
Yes.
And,
but you,
you find a way to make it through that.
As long as you mind your own business and you're clean.
Okay.
You're going to make it a less,
there's just a guy in there that's,
most of them are up to no good with nothing else to do,
but to be bad cause it cause they're not going home.
Did you ever have that thing you,
you referenced earlier,
you said like sometimes you feel like,
you know,
I gotta just like,
Hey,
walk up to someone and be like,
do we like,
I just want to make sure,
you know,
I live here with you.
We have a,
there's no problem.
Yeah.
Do you ever have that conversation and someone was like,
no,
I do have a problem with you.
Yeah,
they really?
and then then that's basically saying like,
so one of us is going to have to do some of that.
No.
After he said he had a problem,
it has react immediately.
Oh,
right then and there.
Yeah.
It had to go down.
So that leads to just smash.
Right.
Boy.
See I hate you,
but you're my people,
so I'm just going to kick your ass.
Hey homie,
get up tomorrow.
You have to get outta here.
Yeah.
If you don't get out of here tomorrow,
we're going to fight every fucking day until you get out of here.
Where's that guy going to go?
Roll it up.
It's a bitch.
Move a whole number.
Rolling it up.
I'm going to another cell.
Whoa.
Yeah,
but he talked like he basically asked for it,
right?
I mean you're saying yeah.
I mean it's
kind of like,
or
like say you're Mexican,
Tom and me and you're in there and oh,
we're not Sally's now we have a problem.
I wouldn't be like,
all right homie.
After lunch,
get your strap.
That means knife everything.
A strap is like our guns.
Get your strap,
I'll meet you in the shower,
homie are right.
Cool.
Cause we still respect each other and we would just stab each other.
Whoever died first.
Wow.
No,
damn.
I want to do that with a couple guys here.
Were they?
Yeah,
yeah.
Do It on the right.
And it's crazy too because I got called out to fight a cop.
I remember there's a song by Dj quick,
he goes,
you're not a killer.
I use a comedian and this full said that to me and I killed her home and use a
comedian and all like,
hey homie,
Mimi in the restrooms for what?
I said,
we need to get down by you disrespected me.
He goes,
I was just saying that to be funny.
I was like,
yeah dog,
but we're not at a comedy show.
Like let's go.
And I remember he was a,
what do you want to do?
I said,
I'm down a fight hummingbird.
If you want to get a strap,
I'll get my strap.
He's like,
no,
no.
Why are we'll do hands up,
man.
I remembered this beating his ass,
got him up,
gave him a hug.
I said,
all right,
we're good now we're good.
And that's how it goes.
And that was it.
That's it.
That's all men do it.
Yeah.
You know,
not that women don't do it like that,
but like that's how we do it.
And it's,
and one of the guys I beat up,
we still fucking talk because of the age,
the Internet.
Seriously.
A lot of these fools are out of prison now and then they're hitting me up.
It's fucking crazy.
I want to get them on my podcast is fucking dope.
Wait,
let me ask you,
so are you allowed to have internet in prison?
Because how are these people meaning?
Because we watched the show,
um,
love after lockup and it's these people that meet their fiances on the outside
and it's like an an online inmate hookups or,
yeah.
So like how the fuck are they?
There's a,
there used to be this thing called,
remember when myspace was around?
Yeah,
there's something called Markel space.
It's where like if we're in prison,
I'll take a picture of me on my shirt off sand it,
and then girls that want to have that life of the Gif fucked hardest.
Fuck for
real.
That's how it is.
That's what I tell people,
look,
if you want it,
it's for real is if you want to get fuck the shit out of mentally and physically
Mary an inmate.
Yeah.
Right.
You know,
that's what they do.
That's you're right.
Because remember the girl with the guy with missing too.
Yeah.
That was her big thing.
She was so hot for him and they got out and they fucked and like a ravine on the
side of the road and she was so in him sexually,
the chemistry and excitement of the sky and then it went and then of course they
don't,
you know,
he can't live on the outside.
He had a trouble adapting the car like on day three.
Yeah.
He wasn't he.
Yes.
Some people just don't,
I mean,
honestly,
I wouldn't have been ready to either if I didn't have this comedy career and all
this stuff to fall back on.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's Kinda hard,
you know,
I'm not them up,
but it's
just kinda like,
yeah,
no,
this is fascinating stuff.
Wait,
so tell me what,
what's your pocket?
Where can people listen to you more?
Uh,
George Perez stories.
That's my podcast.
You guys got to rate,
review,
subscribe.
Please download that shit right now.
I've had fools that had been locked up with,
and it's no comedy talk.
It's just like,
hey dog.
Oh,
I want to hear stories.
George Perez stories.
Um,
and you're also,
you're getting up a bunch.
You're doing shows everywhere.
Yeah.
I'm in Houston Improv the 21st.
That's Thursday,
right?
Yeah.
Well this is coming out.
Yeah,
sure.
Sorry.
All good.
That's all good.
No,
but I mean,
can they find it on your site or on your Twitter?
You know what,
if anybody wants to fuck with me,
you want to fuck up a real Charlo.
Yeah.
George P comedy,
that's all my shit.
George Peacock scare to have all those websites and shit like that.
No,
that's cool.
Yeah,
I'm weird.
But yeah,
I mean,
I got a lot of shit coming up.
I just,
I came here to fucking talk with you guys and show this was great.
Oh man,
this is amazing.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
We didn't even scratch the fucking surface.
Do you know that we have been doing this right now for over almost two hours.
No Way.
Yeah.
Almost two hours.
Ah,
don't say that.
Yeah.
We have two kids to go home too.
That's awesome.
How old are your kids?
One is three and one is eight months old.
Babies,
babies.
We did.
We did the reverse order of,
you know,
that's cool.
You've got adult killed children,
right?
No,
it's cool bro.
Cause I'm 42 yeah.
My son,
my other son turns 21 next year.
I'm 43 I'll be in Vegas with both of my kids in their twenties that's pretty
wild.
Yeah.
Well I'm going to listen to your podcast
and I want to know more about you.
You're fascinating.
Oh fuck you guys are,
I was kind of nervous at first then I was like,
guys are cool.
Chill.
Yeah.
Yeah Dude,
thank you for coming.
What we should do.
This again was down to like we have,
this was way more,
we will,
uh,
we'll mark where we left off and then we'll,
we'll keep going.
So a board that should be the one running the script.
Get more organized.
I like that.
You are a serial killer.
Yeah man.
Yo,
I'm thanks for having my back on the double homicide too.
I appreciate it.
And hopefully you can talk some sense into my old lady,
you know.
Um,
and also I have,
I have put it on mine.
I got it.
So I want to give a shout out to young Patrion and ob one cannoli for making an
original.
So it's one of the,
you know,
people make songs for our show all the time.
They sent this one in and honestly the production,
the lyrics,
they use all the,
you won't know most of the references because the references from like videos
that we've played in.
Okay.
But like these guys just knocked it out of the park.
So I just got to give a big shout out to young Patriot and Obi wan Kenobi for
their original cool guys club collaboration here is,
we'll see you next week.
Thank you George Perez.
Thank you Kevin Christie.
Thank you.
And we'll see you guys next week
with the finishes.
Are you staying clean?
Are You my girl?
Do you really love me on leash?
You really want to kiss but a hot meal face cause you smell like this chuck
Barry Lyndon.
Fuck Steve.
Got them coming fast.
The expiration date pitch or call me back too busy for this.
It
got it.
Got It.
Eating booty blue side.
My father turn
remind you one time fucking bird as fast been $30,000 on his test.
Who was eats mostly from the back of shops at hill,
his 30 beers,
but he loves to Amazon buckets on his porch again,
names hard rock.
Dick got a 12 gauge.
You should try it out.
You can handle this cat break.
Got It,
got
it.